[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right my checks my check what is
going on around
man what's going on man five dollars in
the chat shout out to the Lords and the
best gaming podcast is business all hail
to ILP lower Cognito soft Lord King Lord
attic salute gentlemen salute girl Mac
thank you brother much appreciate it let
me know how my levels
with me right now during mic check
customer says um all your levels are
good
um
[Music]
and
all right I totally both up a little bit
and then uh let's give our hair one more
my check
yeah
[Music]
no questions thank you hustle Astro
parrot gig what's up man you good on the
means so look we're gonna get the rest
of the Lords up in here you know Piggies
will come in so um it will be
interesting
you guys but I appreciate y'all in here
early
[Music]
thank you
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
uses the target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but a man
type social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless of people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal I
got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns uses the target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
a problem
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
nothing but really be Stevo you like to
collect stuff and that's cool but I got
bad news even if you really was that
joke can't ever still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
all right my check might check let's do
a roll call Mic checks talk to the
legend Harold Goldberg we get a mic
check sir
yeah hey everybody how's it going yeah
looking good looking good okay let me
check with you make sure I'm feeling a
little fantastic today a little a little
fantastic
a little bit super excited Mr Fantastic
yeah all right Mr Fantastic
[Music]
all right here you hear me and we are
live welcome to the iron loss podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 296 296 yeah we're
getting close to it wow I'm getting
close to another big number that number
yeah and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's date I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got the New
York video game critic Circle
Diablo 4 beta Castlevania trademarks
PlayStation 5 Pro rumors and Ratchet and
Clank drift apart to PC I wonder whose
topic this is to discuss
how to get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who's illustrious
career not only traverse's music film
and pop culture but whose undeniable
passion for the art form of video games
truly make him an advocate for the
underserved communities within our
beloved Empire State
introducing the journalists author slash
producer and also the founder of the New
York video game critic Circle and the
New York game awards the Lord of talking
games with Reggie and at awards show
Harold stakeshotted he sneaks the day
the dead artwork in the Taylor suit
lighting
and laughed from the Lower East Side and
proudly making his debut into the realm
of the Lords my man Lord Harold Goldberg
of nyvgcc how we doing sir oh man I you
know we have to sign you up for the next
game awards yes yes yes
that is the best intro I've ever heard
that's that is just uh awesome man that
is preaching the gospel on the Sunday
Lord
I'm feeling good I'm feeling good I got
blessed by The Legend of good now
first of all sir how are you doing man
what's been going on with you and also
um what do everything going on with you
have any any games you've been playing
but first off how you do it first I'm
good man I'm I'm good you know the the
the critic Circle as a non-profit is uh
rocking best it can and uh we're
starting a new school we're excited
about it this is the first first time in
the in Brooklyn We primarily are in the
Bronx but uh one of our awesome critics
Sheryl Smith the first
uh black woman in charge of uh
uh uh a tech magazine is going to teach
that class I mean it is that we're
working with her and two of our awesome
assistant mentors so we started that on
Friday so this is good
um you know what am I playing I play a
little uh uh uh I really got into psvr I
know it's a couple of weeks since that
drop but
um that Horizon and I would honestly
forbidden West I I was not that oh I
like the first one but this uh The
Horizon from psvr too
I was down man I was down the first five
minutes all that stuff happens like oh
yes yes
on the kayak and all that yeah yeah I
know Helen's in the other room and uh my
partner and also senior editor on an
nygamecovitch.com and and and I'm like
Oh blank
and she's like what is going on with you
over there I don't you know I'm pretty
usually pretty quiet with with games but
I I did not expect it to be as oh great
yeah it's action-filled as it was yes I
was into it yeah I got into it too I
remember all the segments and then I
actually really started to connect with
me right when you start I started to
learn the bowl and like just the actions
of taking it over your shoulder shoes
yeah stuff like that and then a lot of
climbing a lot of climbing so my arms
got a good workout simulator yeah
but what I realized though Howard did
you play standing or did you play in a
chair
sat down
anyway I mean I would
just I had a pretty bad accident oh yeah
last July yeah so I you know sitting is
a little better than standard for me
right now it's not
I could walk fine you know but I still
have a torn shoulder so oh wow I still
need to uh to sit down from time to time
you know I'm almost all the way back
cool okay great great idea good to hear
good to see you playing VR having fun at
least with all the stuff you got going
on you still get a chance to get it so
that's yeah that's great no doubt no
doubt and you already know we got the
four horsepower well one Horseman down
said some love y'all to learn
[Laughter]
you know what I'm saying in the realm of
course we have our most tactical gaming
Lord the solo game of the list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sostradamus the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the iron bake PC
Master race my man
I appreciate this I appreciate that so
much yes so this week entails from the
master rest
it's like Mystery Science Theater
no no well first of all I want to
apologize to how like I called him
Howard because I was reading a Howard I
said Howard quickly so apologies Harold
but and I also want to commend you on
looking amazing amazing because of
according to Google you're 109 years old
oh wow yeah I'm just trying to get to
80. no man it's it's a it's uh it's just
you know doing good things in games
there you go right right longevity
that's the secret video games exactly
exactly Fountain of you
it's so bad that's dope that's dope
so yeah this week uh I'm playing a
little bit of everything I did I played
some MK I told you guys I was into the
in the fighting game bag this week uh
they did that got back into some
vampires survivors
um yeah I love that game and then what
else what else did a little bit of the
dead cells Castle Mania stuff oh my God
this is disgustingly fun they they need
I hope that if there is an incoming
we'll talk about Atlanta Castlevania
announcement it is these guys work at
least on if they're multiples I hope
they're working on one of them because
this is so good oh my God it's so good
that's the music everything everything
so uh yeah gotta into that oh so the the
Spider-Man the Spider-Man
Odyssey continues
so uh so for context I Harold right I I
got I recently got one of the brand new
uh lap 4090 laptop tops I got a laptop
because I I'm never home so I can't I if
I get a desktop I'm not gonna be able to
use it so I got a laptop and everything
runs beautifully swimmingly on it except
for Spider-Man
for whatever reason Miles Morales no no
uh the the remastered version of
Spider-Man one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so and then during the week there
was there was some sort of update and
when I said let me turn this on just to
see where it's at
and all of a sudden it's like yes all
the frames or the frame the frames came
back it's literally it it was when I at
the moment where I saved the game he's
he's perched he's perched on a building
and then I usually just do the jump off
quickly so I did it and I was expecting
it to you know be a slideshow like it
has been and he just jumps off and it's
like beautiful I'm looking at the frame
rate and then like it's like a 100
frames per second yes Flex wow later
later on in the world oh no
same tub of molasses once again
so it's just hilarious it is this game
right that's kind of crazy does that
normally happen like once it's working
and then one day it's not no not really
it's like Forrest Gump not with anything
in master race the Forest Gump of gaming
chocolate
so again I'll be shelving Spider-Man
remastered until the next pass
the 40 90 update you know yeah yeah no
but one thing I did do that I realized
so the PC comes with the onboard GPU as
well you gotta disable that because
sometimes some games are just dumb and
they don't know how to differentiate
people to the default oh no or they'll
try to battle it out for the two and
you'll get you know middling performance
for no reasons I had to disable the
onboard GPU which
onboard gpus these days are pretty
strong yeah yeah they're pretty decent
yeah so I disabled that and hopefully I
won't have too many more conflicts but
that's it yeah yeah I think I reviewed
that for the Washington Post I'm just
looking it up right now yeah so so as of
2018 and there's
four years later now five years later
there were uh 37 Spider-Man video games
wow 37 yeah since 1982. wow oh my
goodness yeah I remember playing it on
the Atari 2600 yeah yeah we're crying we
can't play just one
you know
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the XS gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that previously
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved Lord cake how we doing sir I'm
doing amazing I'm gonna tell you right
now I am extremely stoked for our super
guests that we have today you guys are
going to y'all went for a treat yes
um what I've been playing this week what
you playing so I've been you know doing
my little fighting game Odyssey I didn't
know I was still online all right so and
I was just kind it was bugging me out
because everybody kept sending me
invites she thinking you offline because
normally I'm offline hiding right yeah
I'm like already seeing this remember
the last Community stream well I've been
you left it on
and my inbox is getting nuts she's here
he's like I want all the smoke yeah I
was getting I was getting weird
questions like hey King I have a problem
with my PC um
quickly turn my stuff off because I was
trying to play my Fortnight in my
fighting games but um I was laying in
bed the other night and I said uh dead
cells dead cells the Castlevania thing
right
tell me why I brought all the DLC but
never purchased the main game
and I thought I did but I was like no
you didn't it came into Game Pass that's
what it was yeah
so could you imagine like it leaves game
pass but I got all the DLC oh yeah that
makes sense that makes sense let me buy
it now um Castlevania stuff is
incredible I just love what they do to
that game and how they can just like um
plug in
different DLC that changes Korean
sometimes a little bit of the gameplay
and the sounding but the animations on
that game like a good game is always
going to be a great game no matter what
time you jump in and this game is just
like that but let me jump onto fortnite
real quick what's up yo I had the
ultimate Loadout I was doing so good I
was down to seven people in the match
wow and I'm creeping I got I got I got
the nice suppress hey y'all it's gold
I'm like epic I'm good I'm gonna get
this this is gonna be the win and I had
my crown on me from a match that I won
already
I saw a slurp truck and inside the slurp
truck let me go inside the back of the
slope truck hit a little uh slurp uh
sips and speed out and I had a plan
I jumped into the truck
did not know that there was a guy that
was sitting in the corner hiding out
he shot me in the chest took my Shields
off with a shotgun and I screamed out
audibly
and I screamed out like like somebody
really accosting it
daddy yo casting now
and
I'm trying to back up
you shot me again he took almost I've
never felt so heartbroken
he violated he violated he scared the
life out of me for it I'm talking about
total I was I was you know how you going
through the world and I was like I'm
gonna get this win I felt real confident
he ripped it away from me and I had to
go on game one daily after that shout
out the game my heart was broken so you
got a great show yesterday on game on
daily because I got thoroughly ripped up
in Fortnight and I love that game so
much that game is probably gonna go down
as probably one of the best multiplayer
games of all time I just set the Battle
Royale Battle Royal culture on fire no
doubt and of course we have the game
against himself the Shinobi no Incognito
spraying that Runner Center Roman IOP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to Mr
Maddie please shout out to Friday dude
had a good one she's talking about the
upcoming showcases Starfield that good
stuff
um shout out the last word he bought
this attack I was talking about Destiny
the new raid content there's a little
debate going on in the community if it's
too easy or not which is kind of
interesting as far as games got the uh
did the day one raid the um not the day
one but the raid after day one so I got
that filing completed over the
nightmares celebrate celebrate
um Diablo 4 beta which was discovered
where would you rate the um this one
yeah um it's right
upper middle upper middle
um it's not better than the Civil Right
no you talk about like all time like
from Destiny one yeah yeah oh no no no
yeah you talk about Raptor machine is
better than this yeah don't get me wrong
like this is middle of the pack it's
solid but it's it's it's it's what I
would say like a lot of extended jumping
puzzles and Ambiance as opposed to a lot
of different encounters and stuff like
that oh it's good it's good so it's
going to be frustrating for people who
can't jump but you got the stadium
it's not that bad it's not that bad but
it's just it's just like a lot of space
between the next encounter all right
we're gonna really we're gonna really
Traverse to this next that type of
energy yeah so we got that but it was
good you learned some stuff and um yeah
I did um Diablo which we'll talk about
and then play a little bit of Guilty
Gear strive which is a gay passer I
thought it's really cool yeah and uh
really quick I know we got I don't want
to be respectful of this time but I
would be remiss if I didn't mention
um rest in peace on Lance Reddick you
know um this was a rough week this was a
rough week for me but personally you
know he's been like the soundtrack to a
lot of my multimedia whether it be like
TV I remember first seeing him King
remember Oz
yeah he was a character named Mo Bae
he's like an undercover he's active what
kind of thing he he was
crossing the line of undercovered
fantastic role obviously
Daniels that character
oh man well he he wasn't he's not Chuck
bodak
he became Chuck bodak hold on for me I
don't got something for him oh play it I
can't hear it what's up how's doing
something I can't hear it so I'm just
playing
I see him yeah I see it but we don't
hear it Harold you got a team no no we
see him yeah man so so he was first a
musician right so so then he got back in
his um musician ways in the last few
years and if you you go you got to just
look up Lance Reddick musician
and listen to some of his stuff because
he is awesome he you know he that's he
went uh um just some super amazing
schools to learn to refine his music
shops and then it was only around like
uh maybe age of 30 is when you start
being an actor right so he's he's he's
got chops that's why I think Keanu liked
him so much is that he was a
he can do so many things
what a loss and then for The Gaming
Community obviously you know he's been
in uh I think it was a part of break he
was in Horizon zero Dawn yeah and then
obviously as a destiny fan the iconic
commanders of Allah which is probably
one of his biggest role he truly loved
Destiny make no mistake he truly loved
Destiny and to see it hit me today like
it hit me this week because I'm I was
just going playing Destiny and then you
see everyone surround his character and
they're all doing these salute emote
very emotional stuff shout out to the
destiny Community for coming together on
that very very we all Titans this week
because yeah he's a big part yeah he's a
big part of it man Fringe lost John
Wicked oh the list goes on so again
sleeping peace King you are missed and
uh we definitely want to give our salute
I had to mention Lance Reddick so if you
want to get the super chances engagement
for Harold yeah absolutely so you know I
don't think we have Harold for that long
at a time so yeah any uh questions or
what not a super chats will come after
uh let me read these first ones that we
got in though
um Gerald Mack member for two years five
dollar Super Chat shout out to the Lords
and the best gaming podcast in the
business ah all hail the IOP thank you
brother appreciate it absolutely salute
and we got hustle and motivating to
build it two dollars Super Chat it's
great to see everyone good to see you as
well my brother absolutely
and we have Robert kellett five dollar
Super Chat blessed Sunday Lords may we
help little Timmy get the 800 PS5 Pro so
you can enjoy Spider-Man 2 at 120 FPS
shout out to your kindness there little
Timmy needs it little Timmy needs it
then we have Robert Kelly to get into
those who chat giving Calvin Call of the
Wild respect call of the mountain sir
called the Mountains
Cold little wild it's wild Chris
stuff that we have said vic H member for
32 months Lord Silva thank you brother
appreciate you and we got um 300 people
here we only got a little bit of likes
let's get started
um really a little bit more at uh 75 for
the road to packs this is our last
weekend before Pax we leave on Wednesday
so if there's any time to donate it's to
donate now
we're about to get out there yeah
exactly about to go do our thing
um shout out to Gerald Mack once again
just gifted five ILP memberships thank
you brother appreciate it oh man I gotta
talk to Dragon heart you'll be gay and
we got Dragonheart you'll be five
dollars for chat hashtag peace love life
to you all especially The Golden Child
addict put some respect on his name oh
for sure I gotta say thank you to
Dragonheart yobi I'm I jump on fortnite
and he sent me
um an emote of hitting the mitts you
know in Creed when he's hitting the Mets
yeah I mean I love this guy I was doing
this all week long just standing there
hitting the Mitch in the corner
salute thank you yeah we got a heartbeat
she need five dollars Another Sunday
another chance to hang out with the
Lords virtually looking forward to
hanging out in real life next weekend at
Pax yes
I'll see you Saturday night most like
let us know what you're doing Saturday
we will figure it out brother we will be
in fact peace come through man always a
pleasure hanging out with you brother
you already know so we are all caught up
oh one more we got Stitch two dollars a
picture is added getting a new
transformed
so he had to go pick that up
[__] because at it so we all good yes
sir all right let's get this thing going
so look now that we uh has been I guess
been very patient do all our foolishness
you know we've done all the super chat
we got to talk about is a legendary
career man I'm gonna start we got to
start from the beginning we gotta switch
off focus this video game system history
his journey into journalism of course
what led him to founding the New York
video game critic Circle and the New
York game awards so Lord Howard let's
start from the very beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming we
gotta even go back gotta go before that
because I started out I started out as a
as a music critic okay okay and uh then
a film critic but a music
um was my passion
through college and probably tonight
mid-20s I did a cover story for what was
a big magazine at the time called
Esquire about music huge
um but yeah man I
you know as a young person I think that
music was um I was always looking for
help in my direction in life right you
know where am I going to go as I was
looking to musicians as well these these
guys are like music guys right these are
the Lords of music so they probably have
something important to tell me that I
can pass on to uh readers at my local
paper in in Buffalo
uh or a Playboy I was at Playboy early
on as well
a lot of questions there we're gonna
continue
the articles are amazing
apparel's life right now yeah yeah we
ain't gonna just glaze over that
so I was at um you know we would do
interviews my friend Michael Hopkins and
I we you know he was he was like very
into
Black Culture black comic books black
[__] just like that you just taught me a
lot of things so we would do interviews
together so we interviewed Sun Rah
together
yeah so Sunrise I just remember like
he's he's making it the beauty of
Sunrise they made one of the views of
Sunrise like he pressed his own records
right right so like we're sitting there
is it here you know
take this how much is it ten dollars so
it was like his own pressing
of uh Over the Rainbow right and that's
still one of my favorite songs to this
day because of like he goes on he goes
out on it it's just like and then he
brings it back what amazing amazing
uh uh uh a song and then um see who else
like Alberta Hunter not that many people
know who Alberta Hunter is she was an
old old uh blues singer who
um would play at this place in in
Manhattan called the cookery so I from
Buffalo originally okay so I got on the
cheap bus
got it I got into Manhattan I talked to
Alberta Hunter before she passed on so
um she's like a blues Legend now and
then I don't know man like Beyonce later
in life and just a lot of good people
who passed on some good good interesting
information to me
Beyonce yeah
I'm letting you know who who you are
talking to here he just he sliding past
Hugh Hefner yeah do a little bit of
Beyonce in here it's a legend please
listen up Brothers listen this class is
essential Harold talking let's go yeah
well the interesting thing about that
Beyonce thing was oh this was later when
this was Destiny's Child right yeah much
later in my music writing uh career and
I just didn't say that much to her but
it was a a Christmas concert Destiny's
Child was doing for BBC and so we were
invited and so we're just hanging out I
said a few words to uh Beyonce so I
wouldn't say it's a proper interview but
I call it an interview nonetheless
because she answered a couple questions
and uh um
so all of a sudden the stage was just
like just some studio somewhere in
Manhattan this there's there's a light
on the stage and the light got too close
to the curtain and so the the whole
stage starts going up in flaming oh
this is different yeah yeah so obviously
you didn't see that in the uh the
concert that the BBC streamed but but
but you know they had to they had to
shorten the show because of the fire in
the theater yeah right that's the story
yeah I'm sure Beyonce remembers that
because you think things don't go up in
Flames every day especially now that's a
very controlled concert atmosphere
absolutely yeah absolutely so did you go
there obviously again this tremendous
you know music background and just being
so close to that so then like how did
these these other lanes kind of merge
for you when it gets you I still have to
talk about music man oh no please please
one more Miles Davis
so there was there was this um
uh there used to be a club here in New
York called the tunnel wait yes sir
hold on this is super gangsters
for proper context in the chat in the
waitress Club in New York this is the
wildest Club in New York like it was
popping a lot of your favorite almonds
go there but it was black would you say
it it saw it goes down it goes down it
goes down listen okay look now I can
give you more context yeah please please
all right set the story the kid from the
South Bronx when we go to the tunnel
now this is not a safe environment right
because when you get to the tunnel the
tunnel is dark the tunnel is So Hood but
this is the place you want to be because
I mean I mean thugs gangsters pimps and
stuff is dead this is it this is
environment environment the gang
environment is there but it's respect
yes it's respect there right don't bring
no trouble there won't you know there's
no trouble
but this is the high of the high yes
it's bad right I'm talking about who's
who Who's Who a lot of you guys want to
know who New York City
influential people are of the night is
there yes now Harold brought up the
tunnel
Sirens
yeah yeah the Beyonce thing but this
thing
because I didn't know how tall Harold is
yes yes it makes it even more gangster
yes the story is a good one man so
I was at a magazine and I get this
invite in the mail and it says
and I forget the designers uh name it's
a Japanese dude but come see is
basically come see Miles Davis and Andy
Warhol wow dress up this guy's clothes
and I said I can't even wrap my ride or
Andy Warhol and Miles Davis the same
thing so so so so so and and and miles
is there he's got this guy's trench coat
on he looks like
um
something not a matrix
and he's got his trumpet he blows two
doses like the two best notes ever and
and there's Andy Warhol there so I know
that the people at my that magazine I
was working for no Andy Warhol really
well so I said well I'm gonna go talk to
Miles man cool looks like he's there and
he and so we had the best
like age just kept going on an hour and
a half he getting his phone number it
just was like the best uh talk you know
it wasn't an interview it was just a
conversation and at the time
so Whitney Marcellus was coming out and
then you know that's why I'm 100. you
can't just be dropping his dance like
that and I had tried to win back when I
was still in in Buffalo
and he was awesome and he was he knew
uh how he had to talk about music yes
and and um and but there was the
president made this rivalry up of Winton
versus miles
okay okay and so I said like there's all
the you know the magazines are saying
that there's this big rivalry between
you and Wynton and he said no no there's
there's it's just they're making it up
man
and like his P so and then I already I I
had read about that Miles had a bad
reputation with with people he didn't
like so I was like so I'm like
dude is just a person man he's just
we're sitting here talking for like an
hour and a half about everything that
just music everything else in the world
and it was like one of my favorite
conversations ever since my Miles Davis
so man yeah I mean that was amazing you
know that's the beauty I think of being
a journalist and the same thing engages
like you get to meet people
uh they have perspective on life and our
our legendary people man they are
legendary people like
uh you know I get chills when I talk
about the Miles Davis
yeah it was a moment so so you know I I
just feel like I was a poor kid from
Buffalo I grew up sick my mom was a
waitress and a single mom and um to me
you know I I the oh my way out was was
writing you know and then my way of
giving back is writing too
no that's awesome that's awesome and if
you could kind of like Channel your
craft you get there you're doing you
know a lot of stuff in the music scene
you're seeing all these amazing people
these luminaries so to speak right and
you're crossing paths with that and then
you know obviously you also have a
background with entertainment and then
you also have the background with gaming
so I just wanted to know like how did
this switch happen because I mean that
sounds like an amazing career right
there if you would have stayed in that
late house right so like yeah I didn't
like the critics man the critics were
bugging me
um that I you know you don't want
critics to think that they are as
legendary as the Legends yeah yeah yeah
so
um
when
you know computers like the Pentium
computer I had the first country
computer I saved up my money I bought a
committing computer CB ROMs were uh the
big thing at that point so this was like
90s that's cool and I'm like this is
crazy this stuff is crazy but I don't
have you know I I I I want everything
and I can't I don't can't afford
everything so
um I
I can't remember how this happened but
the Wall Street Journal had a magazine
called smart money I don't think it's
published anymore but they gave me a gig
and they said you know write about all
these CD-ROMs and games and they gave me
like three pages to do which was a lot
in that magazine they was paying like
three dollars a word so I you know I was
happy to make that that money yeah and
that that you know so then you basically
the same with my Esquire story like that
got me to Entertainment Weekly where I
was a weird critic there for many years
and
um and that's you know that that that's
that started the the ball rolling so I
could I didn't really write for many
industry Publications it was like me and
I don't know if there's a guy named in
guy cruel so end guy was writing for uh
Newsweek and there weren't that many
people who were ready for Consumer
magazines uh
um who were in The Game scene so I would
hang with the end guy and a couple of
other people who did did that sort of
writing and you know we try to say well
how are we going to present X to uh you
know wider audience right so um that's
that's what we did but yeah yeah so
that's that's how it started I had
written a book like so this is an old
book but it's sold like 400 000 copies
so I wrote this book with Dr Helen
Morrison
my life among the serial killers yeah
it's a very interesting book there yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that book sold like
400 000 copies so like I'm trying to
figure out like well what am I gonna do
next and my agent said well you should
write a video game book
and I said no because everyone's renting
a game book like what am I going to say
I don't know if I have anything to offer
but like you said yeah you should do it
so then I wrote
um this all your base are belonged to us
yes about 50 years of video games
conquered pop culture and
um so that was based on 200 interviews
and the good thing about that book is
that um it's the only time the Hauser
brothers ever uh were interviewed for
for a book or for pretty much anything
like Sam Hauser never talked to anybody
oh wow I was the only person he's taught
in the world in the world yes they don't
come outside
even today you know they really don't
come outside that much
um but but uh so those two chapters on
Rockstar were really interesting because
it was kind of like I went through
almost like a job interview to get those
interviews like so I sent them all uh my
life of mine is serial killers to Sam
and and Dan and then uh Jim Colby who
kind of runs the company right now
called me up and said like what do you
want to do
how are you going to take so I had
coffee with her and then I had coffee
with her again and then months went by
and my deadline for the book went by and
I said to my editor like we have to wait
for these guys yeah this is because it's
not it's not a book without them and uh
so one morning I got a call so we're
sending a car free you know Sam's coming
in by bicycle okay
you're gonna sit down in the offices and
then have your talk with Sam so we
talked for eight hours wow wow so those
those tapes are valuable man at some
point let me let me stop it for a second
because I don't want you to to gloss
over that book you know it's yeah it's
pretty much like 50 years of of how
video games in your words and I agree
conquered pop culture where where Now
video games all that de facto form and
you see the growth and you have
basically all these extensive interviews
from all these great innovators all
these games GTA Madden king's quest like
like this whole like how how difficult
was that to put together that sounds
like a very enormous task then you're
talking you know Rockstar which again is
not easy to get access to and Super
Mario Brothers you're talking about like
the who's who of gaming and then how
this transformed into this huge art form
and be dominant pop culture like how
difficult was that it wasn't easy uh you
know me and Mr Miyamoto was hard to get
um for for uh Nintendo as well uh but he
told me some amazing Stories like give
me a mindful story real quick when we
mode a story is that uh Legend of Zenda
Zelda was inspired by him being in the
Boy Scouts Japanese boy scouts and so
they're on like a field trip one day and
they're climbing climbing a mountain
near his hometown and it opens you know
this forest and it opens up to like a
cave and uh and a lake
and that stuck with them so you know
after after did Mario is he had this
idea for for Zelda and that that Vista
inspired uh the first Legend of Zelda
wow that's awesome that's awesome
amazing I'm sorry so I forget no no no
it's just amazing because it is to get a
lot of these guys just don't talk and
they don't to this day they don't talk
to people so to get those interviews and
again to have it in that format where
you're seeing this this sort of
evolution of gaming as this Niche thing
to again like you said conquering pop
culture where it is now this thing
that's ubiquitous and it's everywhere
and you know everybody's gaming in some
way shape or form whether you know it or
not and it's not you know we've had
there are books that have come out
obviously Jason schreier has had a
couple of books yeah you know in the
past couple of years talking about
specific aspects of the industry behind
the scenes stuff then and that's great
too but this one is great because it's
it's it really just is a timeline of how
we got to where we are yes and
yeah and one of the interesting things
is that with the game industry began
they wanted to be like Hollywood now
Hollywood
yeah yeah I mean I remember uh uh you
know it was
at an E3 with um and one of the Sony
reps yeah just why don't you just talk
talk to this guy and the guys uh you
know I'm tired and he's tired and uh you
know he he we both sat on the floor at
E3 and so it like on the side of the
Sony Booth we're just like sitting on
the floor and I had the best
conversation with this guy again talking
about everything not just scans Neil
truck man wow that was there there was
you know deals just a dude and um you
know he's uh he's got great ideas we
talked about literature A lot it was
just you know yeah we still we still uh
know to you know talk to this day oh
that's awesome yeah we need to pick your
brain to get in there because I love nil
yeah we're a huge fan of them it was
awesome man yeah it was the best yeah
awesome it's a good transition because I
did want to ask you about your
editor-in-chief days I had Sony Online
Entertainment like wow you did some
research yes sir
about the Legends and all the
accomplishments but yeah tell us about
that
so that was pretty awesome
um I I wasn't really looking for a gig
but I I don't know where I found that I
think I saw
uh a posting uh for that job somewhere
and it wasn't editor-in-chief at the
beginning it was like um
and it was here in New York and I said
oh I I know the PlayStation people
I bet I would like that job
so I did a lot of interviewing for it
and they hired me as I think a senior
editor or something like that and it was
primarily to do casual games that was
like when casual games were started
starting to be so they had Jeopardy
stuff yeah sorry about I didn't
but it was about to get big yeah not not
the Casual game stuff but they had a
game called EverQuest that they they
were about to buy and
um so every request turned out to be
like one of the first uh MMOs and and it
was like
everyone in the office was playing it
you know people were hooking up because
because a lot of relationships
so it was it was pretty cool I did some
writing for that you know also I found
out that one of our members moved to LA
to work on EverQuest to Scott steinfer
to see that workout as well but in any
case so um I was you know doing a lot of
work on that I did some work on another
game that called Star Wars Galaxy that
didn't do as well uh yeah I remember
that yeah yeah but um so so a couple
months in they said you know Harold we
want you to like do
uh an online magazine and um we wanted
to be like the Vanity Fair of games and
I said well first I said I could do that
for you you know I'm happy to do that
it's exciting but that's above my pay
level man so that's what they made me
editor-in-chief
it wasn't much of a bump in pay because
uh but but so so and I said well I'm
gonna do it right for you guys so I
reached out to everyone I know new I
like
um uh Bill Plimpton the animator was
doing artwork foreign
[Laughter]
writer he'd uh sold 100 million books
like he was maybe second or third under
Stephen King so he wrote something David
Byrne from Talking Heads wrote something
oh uh Michelle Williams the actress
wrote something so everyone I knew I was
like bringing in and they said money is
No Object so I was like spend it
spending so many months
like we like that old style oh so the
energy yeah Gus Gus Van Zant did a piece
a lot of a lot of um good people but the
topic was violence in video games
try to get us out of here yeah so so
they're like
so we're good and everyone is like this
is amazing man the art uh the art
director had done some awesome work on
it and um
um but it goes up to the president of
soe
and they're like
no you can't do it they pull the plug
out of it okay if they pull the plug out
of the whole thing so this is like you
can't do it like if you're gonna be like
this
you know we we're not gonna publish it
so I was like Wow but like you know we
this is not uh uh an appreciation of
violence it's more like you need
violence to tell a story sometimes
that's where a lot of these stories so
that's why we brought in Gus VanZant
famous director right to say that like
violence is kind of key to ever since
Shakespeare the violence and you tell
the story there's ups and downs so so
they pulled a plug on us so definitely
no no get that out of here yeah yeah so
I would an upward you know I I uh you
know Sony wanted me to move to
um to to West Coast to work more on
EverQuest and I was like no I'm not
leaving my family my mom is sick you
know so I can't I can't I can't do that
so uh I stayed here in New York you know
Sony gig ended
um I was writing for a magazine called
Talk that ended and then uh my editor
said well you know what can we do for
you sorry that like your your gig is
everybody's getting his ending I said
show me an agent man yeah like you guys
are hooked up and uh so they they gave
me this this awesome agent who he did my
life among the serial killers so that uh
for a lot of money and got the bag 48
Hours man 48 Hours you sold that yes
it was us because it's not like that all
the time in the world of book publishing
so
um
um so so so then uh uh all your base uh
uh
came up and um that's based I don't know
if you guys ever you know every all the
listeners know what oh yeah
there's an old old this is the first
internet meme exactly belong to us and
um uh you know
I wanted to call it that you know my
editor said like if you if you think
people would find with it but like I
remember Evan nurses so Evan Evan yes
Evan was in our group and he says do you
really want to call it that because
we're trying to you know it's gonna be
Niche and it you know we want you know
it's going to be a good book I know it's
going to be a good book we want a wider
audience and I said well this you know
the subtitle says it and so I I stuck
with it but uh and and you know it did
well but but basically
you know Evan was partially right as he
always is but it but it sold really well
and um
it all your base are belong to us is uh
lying from a game called zero Wing which
is an arcade game and I think uh was it
Sega Saturn something like that Mega
Drive yeah Mega Drive yeah yeah Mega
Drive so
um um yeah I pulled that out and and
called it and it's still you know still
selling to this day it's still selling
decently
um
um it it did pretty well and it you know
NPR made me their uh video game
historian for a couple years after that
and uh Vanity Fair did uh excerpt it so
it did really well man you know you
could see the heart in it put the links
in the in the chat for those who want to
learn you know saying like baseball on
us get some history all that this is
true I kind of use that line you know
with uh with uh Brad Smith
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely now this is a tremendous
accomplishment I definitely want to to
celebrate that and I definitely wanted
to talk real quickly about you know
you have like a little chamber too with
with VH1 that I think is interesting and
like the television intermediate it like
tell me about that chamber briefly if
you can you know when you were kind of
doing stuff so so that so that was the
difference so everyone was blogging
right and so I had was working with AMC
doing vlogging about movies and so then
uh VH1 comes over and since you want a
Blog for us and I said no because I hear
you pay bad
ain't good
will give you a little more money and I
said well I'll tell you well why as if
but you're not going to hire me right I
said no contract because no one there
were very few people uh I at VH1 that
were more than contractors in fact there
was a walkout because they were all
contractors and they were getting health
insurance so I said look
um you give me health insurance
and I'll I'll do it man I'll do it so so
they so so they were kind enough to give
me insurance and that was great nice I
was totally happy with it and um um you
know I did I did my best for them I did
a lot of kind of casual games and indie
games they didn't let me do what I
wanted
um and uh it was good nice nice lovely
I'm glad you talked about it I
definitely wanted to ask about that
chamber real quick oh no side note um in
reference to journalism now right and
and what I would say like the rise of
the the influencer right the rise of the
YouTube because like what many consider
you as like the highly esteemed
traditional you know what I'm saying
journalists so like what are your
thoughts on that you know because we've
had you know Jason on Jason schreier on
from Bluebird we've had you know Gene
Park from Washington Post on yeah and um
they both gave us kind of slightly
different perspectives you know on that
and I'm just curious like where do you
stand on that
I'm more scared of chat gbt than yeah
[Laughter]
tell him tell him Harold yeah but but I
think there's honestly I think there's
room for everybody and uh uh influencers
work hard they're not they're not
critics you know right and um I think
what we uh do as writers is pretty
invaluable
um you know Jason's work a lot of
people's work in investigation
is super important
um you know not being treated well at a
game company is you know people need to
know about that so things change I mean
they are changing
um as far as influencers go man you know
that's that's entertaining people need
to be entertained you know a lot of what
uh uh reviewers do whether they think
it's true or not is kind of
entertainment right so they're trying
they are cons we are Consumer Guides to
let people know if a game is is is worth
their you know seventy five hundred
dollars right and and we do the best we
can they hire us for our opinions
um and you know some some are are uh
nastier than others in their uh you know
I I try to be um as balanced as I can
but there's some games that I've
really dislike because they're not
finished when they're they're they're
put out and then I will come down on
that uh but but
um
you know with the consumer magazine also
I'm trying to like run that
tightrope or consumer newspaper of like
this might be the first game that
uh someone who reads the style section
ever reads or someone who reads the
sports section ever reads right so I I I
also want to explain a little bit of
History that's why I look when I talked
about that Spider-Man review they were
third you know 30 or 40 Spider-Man games
even before that Spider-Man game people
need to know about the history I'm you
know I want people to know about history
when when they read they read my stuff
um so but as far as influencers go like
how do you feel about it yeah as long as
you're not racist and upsetting people
and like calling people out uh and
stirring things up entertain us do some
Let's Plays that's totally fine man
there's insight there there's insight
into let's play I think gotcha no I
appreciate that and um like it's funny
yeah he said that because I think G kind
of said the same thing as well and then
and Jason on some levels which like they
understand you know the shift that's
going on in the same time we still
respect what what they do and stuff like
that I think both Clinton can coexist to
be honest with you you know but I
totally agree with your point on
respectful be respectful in in your
craft in regardless of whether still
human beings Behind these things that
create even if we made this like if we
could comment on the art of the work
itself and maybe quality of it but the
person is to make that that separation I
wanted to uh kind of transition in
reference to kind of like the game
critic Circle and you know you work
there and obviously you know the New
York game awards you know obviously the
Lord's had the pleasure of of going to
our first you know yeah thanks for
coming man that's great absolutely very
prestigious event loved what we saw yeah
the LED Dario Phil Dominus Maximus a
really expensive King as we call it yeah
yes yes yes was was in the building
received the prestigious Andrew Yoon you
know a legend award so he was there for
that so I wanted to get your mindset
what was your mindset behind both
founding the New York video games
critical Circle and then also say hey
New York
we need a game awards like tell me about
that yeah it was ambitious
very yeah we did I didn't really think
about that when I started so I basically
I started it
as uh when when all your baseball uh are
belonged to us came out there were ways
for me to go so one was Hollywood as a
documentary and I didn't trust the
people really that I was talking to
um going back into games so they were
like
I think it's from Electronic Arts that
he would have paid like more than um
yeah so but and so
um but I thought like well maybe it's
time to get back a little and I said
well
there's no group for us here in New York
as most people except for Rockstar is on
the west coast yeah and so
the one thing you know where I show a
slideshow to the kids we mentor and it's
like a bunch of white kids and uh
playing beer pong
yeah acting broish and I said you know
what went through my mind and even as I
wrote All Your Base a lot the line
devices like things are too white
especially back then
even 12 years ago so the first meeting
was Evan narciss who now absolutely was
writing Spider-Man Miles Morales yes and
then
um Andrew Yoon who unfortunately is
absolutely left us past
and then uh Tracy John who uh strong
Asian women of color who never said
Netflix on their interactive movies uh
game type stuff and uh Dan Ackerman Cena
who's not a polygon so those are that
was we wanted to make sure I wanted to
make sure that it was welcoming to all
people and it wasn't going to work if it
wasn't like that and uh so that's that's
that's how we started we started we had
a meeting at the Hotel Rivington in the
lobby and people were looking at us like
why aren't you buying expensive drinks
that's because we're critics man we
don't have that money
um
so so we had we had a good time and and
I I said and then we had I think we had
a dinner and I think Jason schreyer it
just started
was his first uh time as uh either at a
beating Jason was just in like a totillo
called Stephen tortilla called like a
foreign
Awards and Jason basically said you know
but like well how do we get a space and
like if we do an awards and Jason says
well what about NYU I can like help you
guys get the space
and so he's so he so you know
um he did and you know I talked to
various people and we had a nice space
for the first one Rockstar was there
with a contingent they're all been there
every every year
um the first two years we had a panel
discussion before like a live battle
discussion before and I remember uh we
brought Stu horvathon from he has a he
runs a winnable and Stu got so nervous I
thought he was going to die man he was
like not good so we didn't have him do
it again but uh the first one Logan
Cunningham uh was the host okay and uh
uh Logan obviously the voices of Hades
and you know every super giant game yeah
so Logan did a great job and it
proceeded from there you know to be I
think we had like maybe uh 100 or 200
people on I think was called Ustream
then you stream
and you know now we've had as many as
four hundred thousand yeah watching I
mean I wish more people would watch
honestly because it's a good show it is
a fantastic show but but but uh you know
it's it's uh it's enough for me to
fundraise around it and get money back
to kids which is why we do the show
which yeah I saw it it was very
important to me right but my first
interaction with Harold is you know the
New York City Games award just the last
one that just uh passed and you know
we're all there and we're Gathering down
in the library we're getting ready to go
upstairs but I look over and I see this
Dapper man in the corner smooth and I
mean
he stands out because he has this glow
around him and he has a smile and he's
he's looking over at everybody coming in
and as everybody else is you know
meeting each other and smiling and
talking Harold's smile is getting bigger
right and it's I guess it's a
culmination of bringing everyone
together and having this
it was just a weird dynamic this weird
Melting Pot you know uh from zero
financiers to the highest finances to
the most known to the most unknown to
and everything in between it was just
all mixing up and then we found out who
Harold was and I was like it was a
reason why he had that smile there and
he was so interesting I heard the stuff
that she was you know he was talking up
there about um
then I'm listening to you
and and it was something that was
sprinkled there I don't know why I saw
you in that light right but I know now
like listening to everything that you're
saying all the people that you met and
you said movie critic and stuff like
that and it's just great to hear that
you brought all of this together and and
it's a fantastic place for uh you know
Gamers to be so please just go ahead I
just wanted to get that off before you
know no man I'm easily moved these days
and what you're saying is kind of moving
me you know I apologize for that
um yeah it's hard work man because
there's a small group of people uh that
put the show on John as alone and does
all the graphics but I I write it I
produce it yes
I even do the uh
you know the guest list so it's like
we're we're exhausted after that show uh
but I had that suit on I got that in New
Orleans yeah like I had to put the
interests yeah
I was like that was nice I like that
yeah yeah yeah so I got you know yeah
yeah you know I made sure they gave me
that Day of the Dead lining and then it
was like whoa but you know everything
there's always something that surprises
me at uh the New York anymore I I you
know I'm not
super smart when it comes to like being
Savvy and who who are you going to pull
in this year I just like it really is
like in my heart what what feels right
right so Makita Byfield yes we met and
she doesn't mind me saying this so I uh
at a when we were mentoring for 10 weeks
at a homeless shelter about uh
bronxworks and so you know really in
each class everyone's good but there's
probably someone who really stands out
and vaquita is there and like I'm Blown
Away by everything she says when she
interacts so she became an intern now
she's a senior intern she is like you
know we talk about Jason as a force of
energy Nikita is a force of energy and
everyone that becomes a senior intern is
that good at our group but um I I had
heard so Nikita interviewed man engage
uh from immortality and and it it turns
out that uh uh Makita had taken acting
classes in high school she's like like
now first or second year I think
at Fordham
I believe if I'm wrong I apologize you
know but um
um I said well I think Nikita and she
had interviewed Reggie Visa May when his
book came out yeah
and I'm like and I'm like so Reggie and
I are working on a documentary and uh
with this other producer and and after
the Reggie interview I'm like Blown Away
by Nikita it's like wow you should get
like this like this is like god-giving
Talent so I sent it to uh yes and I
don't think Makita knows this I sent it
this to like a guy who won an Oscar for
producing and I said to him
um
like does she have acting chops I mean
because I you know I'm too close to it
yeah trying to get that objective
opinion from us but he says he said he
said he said she's awesome and so
um
um you know so Makita is like going to
be a community activist so she wants to
be she's be a social worker so but I
think if she ever wants to do acting
proper
um she can and I would help her do that
in any way I could but but I said she's
going to be a great co-host she would be
great co-host and like you know Reggie
and I are on the older side
of ogs
2017 you're going to be a little more
mellow on stage right a little more
quiet and but Makita comes out and she
starts it because I knew she had the
energy to start the show and she was
awesome man everyone's like oh she
killed it
so I I said to me kitty and I didn't
want because she was like
all wound up afterwards she just needed
to be by herself for a while because she
just did like everyone's coming up to
her saying how great she did so she went
in the green room and just chilled for
like an hour she didn't she couldn't
deal with any more people but I you know
a few weeks later I I said you're like
can you do it again do you want to do it
next year and she said yes
talk about Makita real quick because I
know yeah yeah because we we got a
chance to talk to her and and
congratulate her afterwards when we were
out in the in the lounge area and uh
just like you said like you know she
immediately you know we just talked
about like what you know where she was
from quickly and and kind of her
situation and again it's that humility
and and like it she had no problem
saying hey I'm just I'm happy that you
know pretty soon my family is going to
be you know we're gonna have a place to
stay we're gonna be out of a shelter and
it's like it was for her it was this
this idea of okay this you know I I was
in this situation I have these amazing
opportunities I'm taking
advantage of everything that comes my
way but it's all from a point of
humility like grateful that this is
happening and uh it just it just
emanates from her the the the energy the
humility and just the you know the the
this ability to sort of light up a room
because again I when I when I saw her up
there initially when the show started
I'm like they have this young girl up
here yeah
I thought
I [__] it up and then you look up you
know the history of you know obviously
we didn't know anything going into the
show about your work in like the Bronx
and with students and things of that
nature so like it's funny because as
were the show is progressing and we and
we literally get to know more about you
the organization the show the people
involved it's like where was this when
we were growing up I can't believe this
yeah oh yeah yeah but it was it was
really an amazing thing and again she
she is a perfect perfect spokesperson
and sort of face for the organization as
well yeah no she's gonna be great uh uh
doing it next year we're gonna probably
give her a bigger role if she has time
for it
um but yeah yeah so we've um
been doing
good non-profit work for about seven
eight years now so once we started the
group you know it was to advocate for
ourselves we did I did that advocating
and we were fine also I want to say
humility if you're not humble I will
kick you from this this group this is
not about one person you know I I've had
to bump a few people uh because you know
they'll always say like oh I'm gonna
start my own group I said go ahead go
ahead if you do that you do that yeah
it's not you know I think it's it's it
really uh um is not easy to do this kind
of thing so no one has ever done no but
but in any case
um someone says Catherine Soros who's
now our our board
uh secretary said to Helen and me uh go
go up to the dream yard Prep School in
the Bronx uh true transmission I was
about to ask you about this yeah the
transition yes and go up there and uh
they needed they'll love to hear you
talk about your career and Helen talk
about her career she's an awesome
college professor who teaches uh writing
for TV and films and Helen is awesome
and um and so but and and you know I I
can talk about games forever and had to
be happy about it you know
um so uh I think the second time it came
up was uh to to tell uh kids how to
write help the kids write their college
essay and I sat down with this one young
man who had just come from Nigeria and
he was like quiet and he said to me um
you know I'm like The Outsider here
and the context is that everyone in that
school is an outsider right
because at that time and you know
either that area of the bronze was
um the the
congressional district that had the most
poverty in that country yeah so
um I said to him
you know I was I I got moved because I I
felt like the uh uh you know I was
really sick as a kid and and I felt like
the outsider in my school and I said
look high school is like this
you know High School is tough and I
think
he said well do you think I'll find my
people in college and I said yes I think
so that's the place you go to you find
find your people and they'll they'll
understand you better than they do and
here here in high school but I was
really moved by that this young man's
words and I went back to the group which
had grown uh by that time to maybe about
25 30 people and I said look is it all
right we've got like 800 years of
knowledge here you know I I counted it
up and it's like look can we do you mind
like I want to shift uh let's do the New
York game awards we'll still have
meetings and hang but can we go up to
the Bronx and and teachers and teach a
class there about journalism and writing
and so people were into it Chris bird
came up Chris is uh
uh uh was at the Washington Post for a
long time as their main critic before
Gene
okay okay
which is Gina's great yeah
and um
um then you know Dan Ackerman came and
taught a class at CNET for like 25 kids
um uh Cherise Smith would come up
um AB Samuel from Daily News would come
up soon so I think we would have guests
and then uh after two years of asking
Reggie cat oh Reggie came outside Reggie
Reggie came up to the Bronx uh to
dreamyard school and and and everyone
showed up man they're like a hundred or
so kids there and our kids as well and
so then a few months later Reggie wrote
some you know and honestly I've I've
hung with Reggie I had some dinners with
him he knew that it was time but I did
not expect to get like an email from
Reggie
um but he said to me I'm retiring and
you're you're one of the reasons I'm
retiring and I thought like what did I
say he's like what did I do with friends
and
um it was no he's like I want to give
back and I saw with your kids a way to
give back and I said oh that's great
Reggie so I went back to the treatment
yard and Kamari renas who's uh one of
our senior interns she's now at uh NYU
Game Center studying uh the producer
she said well you got to get reggied on
your board yes because we had it's a
long process to be a non-profit but we
had just been uh you know we had just
gotten and also I had just gotten an
awesome board together including one guy
uh Ted Houghton who specializes in in
working with uh underserved people yeah
that's been his whole career so Ted is
like the Jeff Keeley of Supportive
Housing
and and then Catherine Rose Catherine
comes from yeah she's a sorrow so she
knows everybody in on the west coast and
her husband Jeffrey they do La Media
fund they've made awesome awesome movies
so uh they were good people and then
Mark Mayer is a great lawyer which is
video game law in Los Angeles but I said
you know uh so Kamari said get get
Reggie so I said Reggie meet the board
and and then I had to meet him again and
then Reggie finally said you're going to
invite me to be on this board oh
would you be a Hollywood
I did not have the temerity to ask
Reggie you know I was too much in awe
but yeah so Reggie came on board
uh it's been it's been great he comes to
host the show now so yeah he's really
helped us we you know we did that
podcast together yep hopefully this
documentary will will rock people's
socks when when we do it and um yeah
Reggie is the best man we're really
close friends now and uh I couldn't
imagine doing this without Reggie that's
an awesome story and I wanted to really
kind of give your flowers on that
because I think
solve we had the discussion after I
think you yeah left at that point you
had to go you had to go out there
because you got other things going on
after the show but being soft stayed a
little bit after it I think what moved
us was kind of hearing the stories
obviously the dream yard project you
know and then you know just seeing again
we all three of us kids so we come from
the South Bronx right and it's very
difficult when we were coming out there
were no programs like that there were no
one coming out to go see anything about
video games right it was forgotten it's
an underserved Community as you
eloquently say like when you found out
you were moved by how you know as far as
the disparity you know what I'm saying
as far as the finance financial
situation in and to see you know the
presentations on stage when we had the
game awards and seeing in these
communities that we come from right and
it was just so heartwarming to see you
know because this is stuff that doesn't
happen especially me personally because
you know gaming was never considered
something you should be doing it's a
dead end thing
taboo why are you guys doing this like
you know the largest so you know how
like our whole Foundation is from
Saturday's Mama Cognito let me I'm
fighting with her to let her be have
people over to play games because the
argument was like hey you don't want me
in the street in these communities but
we're here just having fun playing games
and that's how I won her over right to
allow video games in the house and not
bring my friends together get them off
the street so to see programs like this
to get into video games to get into
journalism to do this stuff is really
heartwarming to see it I wanted to give
you flowers of that because that's
special man that's special we need to
see more yeah we need to see more of it
we need to see more people you know
having lanes and opportunities you know
you guys giving out scholarships like
yeah it was dope salute yeah yeah
scholarships I mean there's various
scholarships every every class we teach
we give a scholarship out but it it the
thing is you're not so I mean it'd be
great if a million people watch the New
York game awards it'd be great if epic
hello epic hello epic
I know some people over there
what's up we're waiting for you to come
come on man you know how many years I've
been knocking on that picture
um but I think they'll come out but but
it grows like so Rudy Blanco at dream
yard so he knew he realized the power of
it of teaching kids with games so now
there's a bronx Game Center there's a
physical space and the Bronx that you
can go and hang out and that's he's
going to get a bigger space now so
that's good so I'm on this uh uh
committee with the mayor's office now
mayor Adams Adams sits down uh uh and
and you know a lot of people there and I
said I said to him I said look look you
know we have to get them youngest not
college is too old yeah we got to get
younger because you look at the
opportunities white kids have from right
on the beginning man right on the
beginning you know they can buy the
consoles
um there's programs in their schools
already
um
so but there aren't in the Bronx so he
he agreed and you know I basically said
to him look
um I I had this one class and
uh it was the last class Reggie had come
virtually to speak and the last class we
had was talking about uh bullying during
online games
when I said to the mayor I said there's
you know one kid he's like 12 years old
he's he's he's playing uh Roblox
and someone calls him uh disparaging
racial
and uh I'm like
he's 12 and I said when did this happen
he said I was 10.
and a young woman gets up and she says
um
yes someone did that to me but they also
said it's hard for me to talk about yeah
they also said they're going to come
kill me and she's 12 years old
and she said I ended up in the closet I
shut the door
uh because I thought someone was gonna
kill me she's 12 years old man yeah and
uh I'm like
schools have to teach this now you know
this is like they could I think they
have to talk about bullying but uh and I
think Roblox is a good game you know I
think most of the time Roblox is a good
game but I think that
the schools need to teach it more than
they're teaching right so so so that's
why I said to the mayor I don't know if
it uh if it if it went through I talked
about Makita as well
um
you know yeah yeah so that group is
there like I could I mean I think it's
important for
game companies to get tax breaks here in
New York yes that's that's not why I'm
there man I'm there to make sure kids
get an education and kids get jobs and
games and journalism all right so the
the bigger question is I mean you're you
guys are opening up in in Brooklyn right
and uh is is the plan to hit the all
five boroughs uh to just like get a
network going where uh we can like
interchange with kids mixing between the
barrels because in the tunnel all the
barrels came together came together
right yeah and uh they did so in Harmony
and usually from there that's how you
met people and you were able to go to
Brooklyn like because if he was from the
Bronx you didn't just go to Brooklyn
right that was not a thing when I was
growing up but if you knew somebody in
Brooklyn and usually you met in one of
these conjugal places uh you go over
there and you go to meet him over there
you go to Staten Island because you met
that guy in the tunnel okay to go over
there and that's how that guy was able
to come to uh your projects in the Bronx
and it was just a network and we we came
from each one to each one so I'm I'm
noticing that you guys open up in
Brooklyn is there any plans to go
further you know yeah yeah no that that
is the hope I mean the actual hope is
that like we put our curriculum online
which is a good one we constantly tweak
it to update it and everyone has access
to it so now we're so that is kind of
done at this point we're just trying to
figure out like the way to rule it out
properly so we'd like to have a partner
like uh Nintendo or Xbox reach out to
the schools that they have a network at
so it's yes we're here I'm always going
to be here in New York we need to uh do
more in the Bronx we need to do Outreach
in Brooklyn wherever wherever it's
needed here in the city but it can be
done around around the country and
around the world absolutely just you
know take our class you know take what
you need take for what you need from the
curriculums you want to do one class on
it uh do it you want to do 10 classes
will help you uh do that wherever you
are this time you know Reggie wants to
do something in Seattle eventually
there's people who want to do it in San
Francisco eventually where all that
needs funding you know we can't it's and
it's hard for me to do it at a on a
small level we need to hire more people
so that's that's the Hope man you know
there's hope to like serve New York City
first and then spread it out absolutely
I I love
I think it's important I think it's
important I think you know one of the
things to get the people who love gaming
they don't know what the lane is
especially in these underserved
communities like how do I get in it and
providing this like you said start with
New York but then from an online
perspective getting the message out
there and then saying okay you could
take these courses this could get you on
the path right and that's one of the
things that kind of you know with us at
large gaming.net we look at ourselves
kind of almost like a feeder system
right let's say hey you don't have a lot
of experience with writing but we got
the Lords of gaming.net we got some
great editors you know submit a piece
you know and then from there we'll help
you maybe we start you a little press
releases things like that and then we
kind of build you up and then we've been
fortunate you know a couple people have
gotten you know positions at Destructoid
or positions at other outlets and stuff
like that we welcome that you know
because at the end of the day you know
we're non-profit we ain't paying nobody
but we're providing this service and
trying to serve the community give give
people a link so I think that's that's
really important what you're doing to
get the word out there and um I wanted
to ask you but as we get towards the end
of this um
you've got so many accolades like
researching you was very interesting I
have to say that because like you I'm
like he's done so much it's the who's
who it's iconic people iconic moments
music film gaming you know with all of
these things that you've kind of been a
part of and experiences you've been
privy to like what are Lord Harold sort
of some of your like most magic moments
or things that you hold near and dear to
you and you were like this this means a
lot to me personally
yeah yeah so I think Miles Davis
interview yeah hang was a it was
important to me as a as a music critic
um
Sam Hauser interviews were were
important to me because no one had done
that and I thought
you know Sam was uh really open
and didn't
stop at any questions same thing with
Dan Hauser when I did a story about Dan
he he was pretty open probably too open
a little too much
Jason Jason
caught on to one line and then a lot of
a lot happened afterwards okay
Jason did you know he changed it changed
everything for the good
um I think so
um so those things but I I really do
have to say that the nonprofit work with
the circle is is uh is way up there
um you know as a as critics we're we're
kind of you know certainly doing as long
as I have and you know at 117 I'm
probably there
you know you pushing 200 there sir
game critics uh so uh you become a
little jaded so uh you know selfishly in
a way we see it off the kids uh when we
go we want to see their opinions we want
to see their eyes light up
um you know we want to bring them
Beyond Call of Duty and Roblox and
fortnite to just open up their minds to
show all the stories of the games that
are out there
um and and you know just to see you know
they don't they you know they may not
know who even Reggie is or Phil is and
you know just give them perspective
invite them to the New York game awards
um just just you know if they're if
they're if they have writing shots bring
them on as as paid interns and then try
to get them an internship at Rockstar or
give them you know Pathways to success
right we call it playing with purpose
and uh um it's a Rudy Blanco and I came
up with that term and nice and that's
that's what we do you know it's it's
like look at what you're playing
um and and think about it you know could
you do that maybe you could do that
this is cool man I love it I love to
hear this kind of stuff again the way
you're serving the community is
absolutely awesome and it it be near and
dear for the hometown you know
you know I was like I have to be a part
of this um a couple final questions that
you know we respect your time you know I
just want to say like I believe that
every so we we don't we don't have
hip-hop Community involved let's go
let's go now so I mean you know I I mean
from the top on down man I mean
you know whoever you think is is on top
now okay and I I would like everyone
from Bad Bunny to okay let's go it's
like it's it's you know and if you don't
overreach if you don't think uh big like
that then no you can't really do it
right so people could say I remember
when I started the circle guys like
someone my boss said Sony said don't do
that everyone's doing that you know do
you can't give back there's people in
schools getting back already okay yeah
there's too many there's too many people
doing that why wouldn't it be special
what makes you special like I don't need
Devil's Advocate
don't bust my dreams it's like I haven't
even started it you're telling me not to
do it I haven't even tried yet don't
give back to other people
they're doing that already do something
else no no no no no no
so uh that's the kind of stuff you do
get so I mean you know John
for Washington post about how he cares
about games John we need you man let's
go we know more people let's go yeah
listen we're putting the call out right
now the Legends in the building Harold
gold you know I'm saying
I support these guys yeah let's support
and then a lot of these luminaries and
uh you know if you know we got to get
people to support man this is important
this is important stuff you know if you
care about the culture right if you care
about Jay-Z I read your book man I know
who you want to do it Hove let's go
let's do it for the Town come on
could you imagine if we can get
representatives from each Borough you
know we have a routine from our Staten
Island
from Brooklyn you know we got some of
these Bronx
what's up that's right I mean we can do
a hip-hop Summit we can give back you
know let's let's get to that point um I
think hope is necessary because I go to
the Bronx at least once or twice a week
yeah I'm from the Bronx and it's
unrecognizable to me at the moment it
feels like a third world country
um
and the the conditions like when you
when you go from one place and you start
to take away the conditions that was
around you and then you go back to those
old conditions that you were living in
it's like a shock to the system and uh I
find that uh depression and low income
rain Supreme there and we need to show
that there's a way out of that
environment to to change we got to give
hope to the kids and that's what I saw
uh you know with Makita I saw a hope uh
so hope when you were giving out
scholarships too
um that that young gentleman yeah the
young brother yeah yeah
I mean salute it's it's and and the
little the little kid the little it was
a little kid I think he was a chess
champ yeah two years old
that blew my mind right
um but his father was so cool yeah he
didn't know me at all I mean and I said
look would it be possible for you know
Tony to come and and and present an
award yes he says I don't really know
who you are the information and I I you
know I sent him some information and
they were there they came man I said you
know I get you know we I said all I can
give you guys is 100 bucks uh from our
from our coffers but uh you know we will
give you and he had you know Tommy has a
foundation so I gave you know I gave it
to his foundation but but he was cool
man that was awesome you know like if
you're outside of Chess you don't know
him so you want to bring in more more
people in this that are cool people that
was so cool yeah but like I said to him
he presented you know the the the
teacher that was cool with he brought
his student yes yeah it was so many
moments like that man again really
really dope stuff it was very diverse
yes oh absolutely we saw all walks of
life there that it was really cool I did
want to say um in reference to kind of
like current gaming and um
one question that comes up in the room
is like you know what's your take kind
of on like the modern day climate you
know obviously we got things going on as
far as the uh Microsoft um Activision
Blizzard King potential deal so I guess
the first question is like how do you
feel about that and then another
question that we got shout out to turn
into the chat was in reference to kind
of like
gaming leaks
and journalism there's a little bit of a
little you know a little bit of conflict
is it ethical is it not you know some
people saying hey you know I I have to
make a living if I come across this
information I put this out other people
say Hey you know maybe you're you're
harming you know people's work that you
know they didn't want to reveal just yet
sort of thing so let's break it down two
questions one current state Activision
Blizzard King Microsoft your thoughts on
that second journalism and leaks
well first if like if I had a crystal
ball
it'd be a lot harder to walk
[Laughter]
yo yo
okay okay well done sir well done well
done good well done fair enough
um but I mean it's it's hard to parse
right so people game companies want to
grow they're obligated to have
uh their stockholders be happy right
um you know Activision been through some
tough things uh and and rightly so
um I don't know if uh Bobby should still
be there honestly
um
you know I I talked to Bobby years ago
for uh you know just after the book came
out and and um
i i s I said you know do you want to do
uh peace I want to say for uh which
Magazine with me and he said he said you
see me no he said no and I'm wondering
why why why because and then you know of
course I would do research my research
right yes and so maybe I you know I
can't you know speak for him but maybe
there was some stuff that you know he
did not want to come out gotcha I don't
I don't know right
um
um you know
Bobby created
an employer and you have to say well
that's cool but within the creation
within the growth there was some bad
apples right yeah right oh so you got to
get rid of all that you have to honor
your people right because if you don't
we're talking about from the lowest to
the highest earlier and everyone has to
be treated with the same fairness yes
right and and honesty and and uh you
know if a lot of the better word love
right and so I don't want to get mushy
about it but that's how we treat people
here and that's how people should be
treated at larger companies as well I
mean I always felt treated pretty well
it's so many other things I didn't agree
with but
um you know that's that's you know
you're working hard you know you're
working not for yourself you're not
really
you know building your own brand when
you're part of a big company kind of arm
and you can get your next gig but you
can't you can't like it you're not doing
your independent thing right you're
working for a team so you should be
compensated well for that and you should
be treated well for that yeah
um you should not be overworked for that
so that's how I feel about the game
industry going forward as far as mergers
go
and you know does Sony have a case does
Xbox have a case everybody has a case
right the question is like what the
judges are going to say exactly and and
um
I I I or or the you know the the
European Union Union is going to say
what's the UK going to say
um I I I I I don't know how it's going
to turn out
um so I I you know
it's uh
I think schreier would have a better
insight to that in a sense well in the
sense that he is a at all when it comes
down to it he is a business writer right
so he knows
um he's he's in touch with his sources
he probably knows a bit better what's
what what may or may not happen
um I'm a business writer you know I take
if I take a story on with a rockstar I
will say either they worked 100 hours
and it's for Jason to say you know what
he needs to say on it um but I want you
know I'm I'm pretty even-handed in my
feature stories um so so so as far as
the future of in in the next year it's
going to be tough for game companies
because we're in this weird we got
really big during the pandemic because
everyone is home everybody was home
you know thousands and thousands of jobs
were created because everyone thought
this was going to
this happens all the time man this is I
mean every 10 12 15 years there's a
shrinkage uh whether it's due to a
recession or uh you know 911 really had
a number under your city
the country so so contractions do happen
and then it grows again so so
um you know uh would I say Facebook you
know at Twenty Thousand Cuts is too much
probably but though I think that
everyone will ramp up again in a year or
18 months top so and there's still you
know we still have a good amount of
unemployment but I you know again I do
not know the ins and outs in business
man I'm just a writer trying to write
and you know give me give me a story if
someone comes and gives me a story do
the inside story of Activision uh
blizzard I'll do my best to find every
detail possible but from as an outsider
as a game fan as a journalist
um you know every everyone needs to be
treated well and whether this merger is
for good for being treated well
um I I don't know gotcha no you'd be an
objective just that's where you are
right now also I did what not let you
get away from the um the inside leak
leaking stuff okay so um yeah we're
gonna get back on that
um so so where you at with that because
this is a big contentious part in
journalism right now I've got friends on
both sides I won't name names so leaking
footage from a game do you mean
a story let's just use an example like
Rockstar right um you know someone may
know what the new title name is or hey
the release you know they you know
someone may say hey I I think you know
this Grand Theft Auto 8 is going to take
place here and looking for 2025 release
you know and then they they put that out
and as on their platform maybe they're
you know consistent with that versus you
know the other side which is like hey
you know I don't think that's cool and
then you know from a journalist
standpoint so where do you sit
foreign
side of investigative journalists okay
some dude sits uh somewhere and get some
information I don't know if I could
trust the the guy or the woman who who
leaks it but maybe uh I can okay I I
think one thing I do know is that from
when I started going to E3 everyone was
accessible yes like every person they
just wanted to be written up in
Entertainment Weekly or wired or
something like that it was like a joy
for them I mean to have uh you know
Ken Levine who was making Bioshock in
the New York Times they're just really
happy even though you know I I said one
of the things I said to him they were
very cagey about is like how much
BioShock Infinite costs like I can't say
that I can't say anything
so whether you can say that or not I'm
good to find out so I did but um um
uh you know I think
all those leaks considered journalism
that that's the argument well no no I I
I just want to I'm sorry
of History here so now you can't knock
it down the door
of Nintendo is harder than it was
even 12 15 years ago everyone's tighter
lipped now everyone wants to have their
own stream and their own influence or
their social media coming from game
companies which is sometimes cool right
you see trailers from Sony and Microsoft
and and Nintendo in their own streams
um but I think that if you find a nugget
that is important
um someone tell him
it's it's it's it's it's not a bad thing
okay ultimately it's not a bad it's not
a bad thing and I think the game
companies might come down on me for it I
don't like because I know I'm in how
many people work on it from the bottom
on up I don't like seeing game footage
leaked I feel that okay
um I just feel like
it's not finished yes
um it may not end up in the final game
um it's it it doesn't I don't know if it
serves fans well right and
um I'm not the person leaking it you
know maybe the person has like the the
reason why it's the accolades wants to
be uh known
um is maybe feels they are doing a
service but
um
I I I don't like it now if you're of the
opinion that oh
media is good media so maybe then it
doesn't it it it it doesn't it doesn't
hurt in the long run I mean if if a
company puts out a triple A game and
they know it's going to the top it's
going to sell a billion dollars in in
you know within the first week probably
not gonna you know the leak is not gonna
hurt it as much it's a big problem for
those marketing and uh PR folks right
yeah absolutely but
um
um you know I try I try to look at all
sides you know I'm a Libra right
gotta balance it but
um honestly
if you're I I just go back to like if
you're an investigative journalist if
there's something bad happening at a
company you gotta say it if it comes to
you like why are you gonna hide that if
someone is being abused at a company you
can't hide it I I hear where you're
coming from in reference to
investigative journalism has been
reference to leagues and then I do like
what you said about footage because I
think being kind of an alignment here
pretty much all the way I think I'm okay
with it for the most part minus the
footage because I do feel like like you
said like sometimes it's just it's just
a you don't get the full context right
and then it it deserves the the the
actual people who worked on it and then
you know that it it creates a narrative
sometimes that are not fair to to the
game in the coming so I I don't like it
at all because it takes a way to wonder
I'm I'm yeah I like the Wonder and I
don't want to know all about the script
ahead of time I don't want to know the
plot ending at the end sometimes I I
even skipped the trailers I mean but
these big shows I think they need our
eyes on it as far as like E3 packs stuff
like that
um and there's the award shows those
need our eyes but as far as the leaks go
I'm not a fan of that stuff yeah I will
say this though I will say that there
are people there some of the biggest
stories I've come from people inside
actually you know the the actual dabs
bring the NDA because they want to to
Harold's point they want people to know
about some unfair stuff that's going on
okay you know whatever whatever and
sometimes that actually brings about a
greater change you know obviously with
certain things so it's a tough one but
I'm glad the legend you know say it
don't just with that one you know what I
mean but um yeah we got Tom Henderson in
the chat oh yeah every leak comes from
someone breaking NDA and he said he's
never broken India appreciate it shout
out to Tom appreciate it there are ndas
man there there are ndas
um
but if you're look
if you're being sexually harassed if
someone leaves that you know so Jason is
not you know Jason gets a lot of uh
credit and Readiness but also a lot of
abuse yeah
um
you have to find
not that necessarily that one person but
you have to find it uh as two people
three people four people five yeah
kitchen to to to be
um
and honest
well balanced journalists some people
now I I'm old school man so I still tend
to look at things uh through to give
everyone a say right but there are a
number of people in the group that say
well no you have to be an advocate as
well my advocacy is with the younger
generation of American who are
underserved in homeless that's where I
go for that right that's that's where I
and that's a that's a that's a heavy
lift uh but I want to make sure so
what is it like 2.5 percent of black
people in the uh game industry right now
so I'm doing in in my little small way
trying to make it make a difference for
a number of kids and we've you know been
lucky enough to make a difference for a
lot of kids over the years but we can't
take on that many each year right um but
that's that's the key to me man if you
don't have a way out we want to help
facts it's and and and and and the other
stuffs is important stuff but that's not
where my advocacy lies absolutely salute
and I love what you said about again
underserved communities provide that
opportunity you know I'll be honest you
don't say king so I'm like you know we
didn't see a lot of people like us you
know what I mean you know coming up in
in gaming you know so it was it's
refreshing to hear about that and you
know I speak to my brother you know
hip-hop game is one that you know one of
the early ones we used to see I'm like
okay he's doing content creation stuff
like that or when you see you know
different you know developers you know
whether it be of color or anything it's
very heartwarming to see it's it's
changing yes it's moving forward it's
progressing I remember the first time
when I saw Reggie and head of Nintendo
I think that was transformative because
you know Nintendo was if not number one
number two and you know to have Reggie
as you know the face and and I think
that's when Nintendo really started
turning the corner as far as being
globally recognized I thought that was
huge and you know to see him say okay
you know I'm gonna retire now I'm going
to give back I think that's even greater
so you know we're we're moving forward
to where we need to be so yeah no doubt
yeah yeah and that you know what you
said about Hope is really important you
can't
you can't let it die man you have no
matter what happens you still have to
hold on to it because there are folks
out there that uh are willing are
willing to help and and and uh and even
if not you just you find it in yourself
to keep going that's what we do that's
why humans have evolved right like we
just keep on going uh
as best we can because what's the
alternative right yep no absolutely
absolutely and then who who better than
you because of your accident I mean when
you said your accident and people I
think we have to approach that let's get
it you see him right now and you see him
when he was on stage and you have to
explain your accident to uh the crowd if
you would like to
um and and it felt like Rocky to me like
him coming back yeah type of thing to
get back to this space to to be even
walking like you said you walk a little
bit it hurts a little bit but please in
your own words please explain to them
yes so
um
uh Helen my partner got uh kovid and uh
when I was at Sony I had a little extra
money and I I bought a small place up in
the Catskill Mountains just to chill and
she said well you know I'm sick you know
maybe you should go up there so I went
up
and I remember I had
some uh small there's a lot of cool
small events that go on in small towns I
was going to go into some art gallery
opening to hang and I said oh man I
could do some work it's like an hour and
a half away so
um uh I went and uh tried to do some
work on uh The house's balcony and I I
fell like about 14 15 to see
and uh so it's just there's nothing
there's no hospitals up there yeah you
know so
um you know I could not move man I
didn't know what was up like I couldn't
move I could crawl and I went into the
house and I tried to put weight on my uh
right leg I could not do it and so I
crawled back out because I my phone was
in the house and I was gonna like
try to call somebody I wasn't I was kind
of in shock and I saw someone going down
the mountain with the base of a mountain
and I was waving to the guy and he's
waving back like everything's cool and
um
answers are you hurt and I said yeah
yeah so they he called the local uh
ambulance they came and they said did
you hit your did you go out do you
unconscious I I don't think so man like
when I hit just did you hit your head I
don't know man I saw like a brightness
but I don't really think I hit my head
they said well you know we've seen this
before
um you could be bleeding inside so do
you want to go you know to we need to
get you to Albany and I said what and I
said I don't think I'm bleeding this the
guy said no no I think you're probably
bleeding inside in some way and if you
go to Kingston hospital and that's in
itself is like 45 minutes away if you go
to Kingston they're not good they don't
have a trauma yet right you need to go
to Albany so it was what was cool is
like I think I mentioned on stage it was
like GGA or something helicopter
helicopter but it was kind of stupid
like as they were putting me in the
helicopter they hit my head again
God
so like uh they got me there and and it
it was not good man so my my pelvis was
broken in three places my arm was like
huge and black
um I had a subdural hematoma uh
concussion
uh multiple tears of muscles and uh uh
so it was so I'm like uh you know Helen
is like what the what's going on I said
I'm all right you know they did they did
it they did it they did quick operation
but I wasn't all right and
um
uh
it was I I you know I said well you know
what's going to happen with the circle I
was like you know there's your first
Focus
well you know what's going to happen
well first Helen and then uh the uh I
was like what's gonna happen to these
kids like how bad Alex am I
um but so a friend of ours from the cad
schools drove me back home it was I was
a mess man I was uh you know I was on a
walker for like a long time wow you know
Helen helped me like walk around outside
a little bit it's just you know it's
just it is the thing is things you go
through and then
um
then they found so with you know there
are lots of CAT scans and MRIs and all
this [__] excuse I'm sorry
this experience
so yeah I still have a toward shoulder
which is bugging me and uh uh but but it
you know
within so we were doing a virtual
uh kids from the props for making these
virtual twine games so like within a
week I felt good enough I still had to
walk her but I could still sit and help
the kids make twine gains with this uh
awesome interview at from NYU so so I
was I was back best I could you know
Reggie was on the phone with me like
immediately how you doing so so
um I was pretty scared honestly but it
got better so I'm you know I'm I'm I'm
rocking it rocking it now so but it just
made me honestly it really and is this
the cliche of people uh you know and I
pardon me for that but you do look at
you know hope is even bigger than after
something like that and you do look at
the world as like oh I'm still here man
I'm so happy to look at things outside
and you know uh he's noticed things a
bit more than you do and just happy that
you know uh you're still kicking oh no
absolutely I mean first of all
tremendous when we found out you know
thank you for bringing it up because
when we found out we were just blown
away you know and he was still doing the
things you're doing and just an
appreciation of life right and you kind
of you see that and salute man because
again
not only fortunate that you survived
something is is awful is that you know
the fact that you you still for the most
part you know have perspective and
appreciation and went right back to
doing what you do and you know easily
you could have stopped and just focused
on your health which everybody
understandably so would have had no
issue with it so um that we want to
salute you on that uh really real quick
I do want to break protocol with one
thing as far as Super Chat saw on
Michael Santiago medic yes he said it
was an absolute honor and pleasure to
volunteer for Harold at the awards what
Harold does for the development of the
youth in New York City is Herculean so
shout out to two men oh man he was
awesome man that that you know I met
that guy at another invention and uh
he he was like I want to help out and
and he did everything man he went to
like a Costco to get to get snacks and
and beer and everything he just he just
really went over a boat good dude yeah
good dude we also met him at uh playing
NYC shout out to him shout out to
Legendary damn blitzko and we used to
support him as well but uh yes
tremendous man what I want to do the
final question that we asked all the
guests in the realm this tradition how
no pressure no pressure
I need your top five video games or
franchises of all time
oh any order you know I someone just
actually
let's see uh let's see
and just like this let's go he got it
he's ready I'm getting it for you he's
getting he's just digging in the crates
let's go yeah yeah
so this is as of now right yeah so I can
go 10 really quick
the Red Dead Redemption two I love that
let's go
you're welcome here air anytime you want
sir it's obviously the shirt see y'all
ready see I'm ready ready let's go
and I have to I did not expect how good
that was I mean I hate you know from
software killed me so I did not want to
play another from soccer
I was like at least at level 100 now
Bioshock for the narrative perspire
shock uh Zelda breath of the wild
yes uh last of us both but it's part two
definitely okay do you agree
okay uh Soul Calibur three because the
fighting game okay
well because it was for the Dreamcast
and the Dreamcast was an awesome machine
it would allowed you to move around uh
the um the platform in almost a circular
motion so it wasn't 3D but it kind of
felt 3D so it was awesome and then
mainly the myth behind each character
nightmare forever oh nightmare nightmare
had a nightmare right now he's showing
me the Dark Side of Harold now listen
when Harold Harrell said uh Studio 54.
yeah I should have known I should have
the dark side
uh Tetris I think
uh NBA Jam man
like who didn't love big head mode right
he's on fire joyful man he's eating up
from downtown from downtown
let's go uh Hades
let's go
and I think you know just more
just more of appreciation because I did
a book about a League of Legends just
because you can change things right it's
got some problems they're working out
some problems but
um League of Legends and also that I saw
one of the things with League of Legends
I saw and then no one talked about now
they're starting to talk about is that
when League of Legends started they had
like some dude or woman walk in a bag
writing
narrative for each character and you had
to really search to find that so I found
that like there were always like uh
Teemo was meetings like some iconic big
character like everyone hates Tebow but
like somehow this guy's me like it's
almost like a Game of Thrones or
something and I was like no one's
talking about that that's kind of like
God one of the things that got me hooked
into that game while I was playing it
and writing the book and um
so so yeah League of Legends is on that
nice
he had his 10 ready like yeah I was
ready like he's the first guest ever he
had 10 off rip he's like all right I'm
glad God uh you know um Whatchamacallit
came in at uh Fortune the last of us too
oh yeah yeah there's top there's top
yeah we noticed we didn't notice what he
said first all right we know the Red
Dead yes
we'll see what happens with Last of Us
three
and final questions we asked for all the
guests in the realm favorite console of
all time and why
yeah yeah
um man it's a toss-up between
PlayStation 2 and 360.
360 for the rise of indie games yes
Xbox One PlayStation 2 which like
changed everything like Sam Hauser told
me they would not have Grand Theft Auto
3 without PlayStation 2. really right
because of that uh the processor allowed
them to do that open world then so so I
had and and just even that blue light
the glow of that blue light man at the
night at night time yeah I would have to
say PlayStation 2 so yeah tremendous
yeah that PS2 actually again the
legendary absolute pleasure to have the
legendary iconic Harold Goldberg in the
realm of the Lord's an absolute a man of
his word too because you know song
Sometimes you run down on people yeah
and they give us the the spiel how it
was so a hundred percent and transparent
and he was like Cog I'm there and it
meant so much to have you here to raise
your journey to listen to your story to
listen to what you're doing for gaming
gaming culture the Community Education
you know serving underserved communities
and then just again also celebrating all
the celebrating Peters in the industry
the developers I mean we could talk
story The Music stories I could have
talked about I want to hear more about
the tunnel and miles and more stuff and
who else
yeah I know I'm sure you have a couple
of Limelight stories as well
there's some New York stories we could
have definitely got into and I know
obviously you're always welcome back
it's a tremendous man tremendous story
so again tell the people what you got
going on where they can find you you
know what I'm saying and things that we
could do to maybe support some of the
things that you in the movements that
you got going on yeah yeah so like uh
and
nygamecritics.com is 95 written by
underserved kids students and then you
can find a link there to donate put it
in the chat right now
and then I'm at Harold Goldberg on
Twitter
link to donate there as well link to all
your base if you want to buy that is
there okay we gotta get that book and um
um yeah that's you can you can find it
you find me anywhere because
um you know social medias are you know I
would care less about social media but
it's our way of like telling our story
and the story of the kids that we uh we
helped serve so that's you'll be hearing
about our four-way into Brooklyn next
week and look after and uh that's you
know with Cherise Smith is going to do a
great job with that Cherie the
editor-in-chief of laptop Isaac Espinoza
Ronald Gordon associate mentors so yeah
we're gonna we're gonna do it and then
oh one last thing I have a novel coming
out called the skinny oh nice and uh
that is in the fall so uh you'll hear
more about that it worked really hard on
that and where have you been yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but there there's some it's it's a it's
a mystery novel about 1990s New York
City oh I definitely want to hear about
that
we was outside
let's go and there's a there's some game
inspiration and also a little bit of
inspiration of uh
some mystery novels that I really like
like Devil in a blue dress
salute to the legend Lord solve outros
for the legend what they want to say to
me that blessed us today in the room
I think Harold that um
in listening to like this breakdown of
your career and your life and these
accolades that you have
the most striking and most important
thing that I've gleaned from this is
just the human being that you are
above and beyond anything else
um
I still live in the Bronx
and I pride myself on being someone that
is from that environment but not of that
environment and I
I'm lucky in that way right I'm lucky in
that I grew up around people who felt
the same way about hey we're from here
but this doesn't Define us and this
isn't this isn't what we're going to be
and when I talk about that I mean like
looking at you know as someone who still
lives here
but
doesn't sort of engage with what you see
day in and day out
the level When We Were Young growing up
you were you knew you were poor but
there was Joy still there was Joy it
wasn't the same today you know life is
hard life is hard and it's so easy to
take the joy out of a child's life at
such an early age and never find a way
back
um and to feel hopelessness at a very
early age and never find a way back
because you're just so inundated in
negativity negativity uh and and just
poverty and things of that nature every
single day
I'm grateful that you know that wasn't
my path that wasn't cog's path that was
in King's path
but I'm doubly grateful that someone
like you who didn't grow up in that and
but saw the need and I think that's what
makes New York special right when you
really talk about New York as a Melting
Pot you grew up in New York your ideas
of what racism is and and sort of
looking at people differently isn't it
quite the same thing
as maybe in other parts of the country
because you you know every single day
you walk out of the door you're seeing
people with different races Creeds
colors it doesn't matter and that's a
special thing that I I don't think you
see in in all parts of the country or
the world and so for somebody to see
that and see that need still Within
These communities and create a space for
these kids who
you know I look at my nephew and he his
love of Pokemon and every all things
Pokemon is so pure and
for that to ever be taken away from him
because of what he sees around him would
be heartbreaking to me and my sister
does a great job of every single day
making sure no you you're gonna study
you're going to do this you're gonna do
that and but not enough of that happens
so to see what you guys are doing in the
city to give you can't save everybody
right because you know it's
it'd be great to be that idealistic and
to be able to to be able to do that but
that's just not the reality but every
single kid that you can
get to look at a video game and say hey
I love that whether it's the
storytelling the gameplay the the the
Curiosity of figuring out oh how does
that get made
or I want to just talk about them or
write about them that's all it takes
that one moment to change you for the
rest of your life and make you a person
that understands and comes from an
environment but not
continue to be of it and
I'm so grateful for for the opportunity
to go to the award show this year get to
meet you get to understand what your
organization is doing and hopefully in
the future be able to help in some way
shape or form because again born and
raised in the Bronx I heard the Bronx
the Bronx got brought up like 10 times
during that night wait a minute what is
this
exactly where am I Alex
so I just just very excited to to see
what's what's going on moving forward
you know what you were talking about
with the the committee with the with the
mayor's office and how you know the
plans to even start to implement sort of
gaming related things into summer youth
programs
and I was going to touch on that but
I'll let you finish yeah but but again
thank you Harold I I truly truly
appreciate and respect the work that
you're doing thank you thanks man well
said man thank you no doubt Lord king of
outro for the legend
All right so I I'm super happy my wife
knew I was so happy for today because I
was like yo we got Harold on this Sunday
it feels like the guy that you were
talking about because after meeting you
okay well I saw your aura standing there
and I'm like it didn't know who you were
right but I was like yo he has like a
magical order around him right all right
and then you get up on stage and then I
find out who you are and yesterday I did
an interview last night and you know the
guy said man you're the most interesting
guy you know that commercial the most
interesting guy and I and I and I
stopped him I was like no no no
I said we're having the most interesting
thanks please tune in and I don't think
this two hours that we had with your
hour that we have with you
um doesn't really give us a chance to
encapsulate who Harold is oh facts now
when I grew up uh younger I'm a little
bit older than these guys here yeah and
I grew up in the Bronx and I grew up in
Melrose projects and in the Melrose
projects and every project in New York
City there used to be a community center
in the community census is also was the
the PBA the Police Association
was that you had housing police and they
always worked hand in hand right so you
always got a chance to see uh police
presence and you also had the community
centers that would serve the community
as far especially that project right so
there you would have some of youth
programs
you will have daycares you will have
after school centers and you have things
that will give kids an outlet because a
lot of our children was latchkey
children yeah this is the time where
video games really started coming up so
uh sometimes if a parent was still at
work they would have a console and
usually that one television would be
there you know it's just your time you
know you do your homework you play your
video games before your parents get home
and then they come home and then you
know they take over the TV that's kind
of pretty much what it was but I only
said this because
um I grew up in the community center
programs and and it helped me get a job
this I started off with some of Youth
yes and having jobs with the community
center and working with children and
then I was uh working for New York City
Housing Authority and I became the
youngest New York City Housing Authority
director in New York City history I made
the papers for that was great right
um and what I would do is I would bring
my consoles I was like always on the fun
front for foreign
I would have video game uh time with the
kids right so the kids that didn't have
a console couldn't get a console or
whatever you know we had a 32-inch
television yeah let's sit down and let's
play and this is our interactive time
during that period of time so and I
would do that across going to different
community centers and then I noticed
that other community center directors
started implementing that going forward
right now sadly community centers are no
longer in New York City right uh They
removed the monitor projects and
children do not have that outlet and do
not have those abilities to show that
you know video games can be something
constructive than rather destructive so
when Harold and his organization was uh
you know in the Bronx giving hope and
showing video games and giving
journalism to children I said this is
the most interesting man in the world
because he's uh doing something that was
removed from New York City the detriment
and he's doing it in a positive manner
and it's going to grow from there and
here that you're going to Brooklyn I'm
trying to do this really quickly
but when I tweeted at you and I was like
I hope to have you in the room and you
tweeted back I almost had a heart attack
and he was like sure and I swear to God
I screenshotted it I ran to the chat I
was like please somebody talk to her
over here I'm like all right good
morning I said we did talk we did talk
in person but you know I wanted to see
it he kept his word you know he kept his
word because a lot of times we you know
around wants us to get you know guests
like that and if it came to be that
passionate you know what I'm saying
about it I knew it meant a lot I'm glad
you brought that up Kate because again
you know I remember those times you know
the community center and these are rough
project that cake is talking about he's
not we talk about Harlem we talk about
certain aspects and and and I remember
going there he would be like you're like
oh yo because we used to get some of the
import games early or we get games right
hey bring them to the community center
the kids might want to see that and it
was a it was a cool environment and you
could see the kids really appreciated
that time and video game look I'm not
ashamed like video games saved all life
it took us out of bad situations that we
could have been involved in and I I
think people are losing that aspect of
how important it is and creative you
learn through video games so again
salute to you on that and your journey
you have a friend in the Lord's laws
will be there to support you and of
course the game awards and all that good
stuff much appreciated the legendary
Harold Goldberg
thank you guys man this is honestly
truly the best podcast I've I've ever
done thank you this was you guys
understand I I understand what we're
trying to do and hopefully we'll
continue to do it and and uh King just
one last thing I hope you don't mind is
it's you are right that it it's you know
those community centers in the Bronx
that
sounds like it was so important you know
there was a community center here on the
Lower East Side and they were
kids there were supposedly there's told
they told us that well these kids may be
dropouts they yeah they go the wrong
path so uh you know yeah this is what
you're going into so that that was tough
but I think we made a difference
uh one kid basically uh he and his
brother were twins they were quiet for
like five weeks and I said guys
come sit with me we need you to do you
write your review uh so one of them came
up and he had again he hadn't talked the
reason he hadn't talked is that he I I
asked him what his favorite game was and
uh I think he said it was like a Call of
Duty or Modern Warfare and I said well
why is that he said that's the game I
played on the day our father walked out
and and he said you know uh I played
that
and then I would cry and then my mother
came in and we both play that and we
would cry again we played it all night
and that's why that's the most important
game
and so uh but they didn't ask us back
and I feel bad because I think we could
have made a continual difference I mean
that that that kid did become an intern
with us
um but I think we could have made a
difference uh more of a difference here
on the Lower East Side but
um we'll still try it and and we're
growing every day to new classes and
thank you so much for for taking the
time to let me tell my story for sure
and for for understanding what we're
doing for sure for sure for the chat you
know again I just want to put the your
information in there you know we got
obviously the website and obviously the
uh the critic Circle and of course the
book as well so I'm just going to put
that information in chat so again so
people know where they can go and how
they can reach you to support all these
fantastic things you're doing for gaming
and supporting the culture of gaming the
art form of gaming because we are arts
and we are the biggest in pop culture I
will say that following us now it's cool
to be a gamer now
side before was it cool
brother thank you again for your time
enjoy your Sunday the legendary Harold
girlfriend thank you so much brother get
them back and when the skinny drops oh
yeah
all right man that's it that's
definitely man we'll do it appreciate it
thank you brother enjoy yourself thanks
so much you guys as well thank you you
are welcome all right so I'm gonna get
the Super Chat yeah get the super chats
let me see okay we already read Michael
Santiago thank you brother appreciate
that we got Suicide Kings remember for
two years five dollar Super Chat put my
dollars in the collection plate and
passed it to the left thank you brother
I appreciate that appreciate that and we
got David hot right remember for one
year 50 Super Chat go give Pax that
business
my suitcase is getting packed up this
evening yeah
yeah yeah I'm running late on that I
need that yeah
I'm usually the earliest on that now and
what sucks is that Saturday uh Caleb
plant fights uh David benavidez I'm
supposed to do a combat talk with the
king oh I gotta be watching it there so
I'm gonna give you a fresh uh free and
and then poster but uh yeah yeah so I'll
probably be toast but that's exactly yes
Saba will be there so he might interject
you know you got the baby that's right
uh let me see Suicide Kings once again
remember for 28 months Lord bronze I
know we're a gaming podcast but can we
get this gentleman back to speak on his
music stories he's chatted with Legends
oh and just asking for a friend
I wanted to get into his movie critics
stuff
he's so much you listen guys this is a
condensed version of yeah
I'll be honest you know pride myself and
try to prep he was one of one of the
hardest people to prep forever we gotta
pick and choose
we have that hour and a half and it's
just like what do I focus on like
there's so much to it right so it's just
like you're like kicks in I love to have
a back because you never really got to
his yeah
you could tell how important the music
apps yes he was against I said you know
what let me let him go because this is a
chap that a lot of people don't know
about so I was like let me let them cook
yeah the music we knew that from the the
award show when he had the guy remember
the guy up there doing the Halo yeah
yeah yeah so and and you can tell that
he's jazzed out like he was in that
scene he said the tunnel baby
the tunnel
was there was an intersection of all of
New York there like you had nights where
it was like you had you know the the the
club kids as you call them and it was a
really wild psychedelic stuff and then
it was nice that it was Hood straight
Hood that's the olfactual and it was
just like much like the Limelight it was
a place where people from all over the
city
it was a party thing you know that was
for recreation
are you implying that certain activities
if you were going to you know get
medicines
medicinal situation I remember one time
at the Limelight
yeah
yo Jack had a birthday it wasn't the
Limelight though that wasn't something
yeah this wasn't the Limelight story
Shaq was someplace else I can't remember
Jack was no that was a Palladium
Palladium
birthday party at Palladium and and you
know we get in and we walk in and we
adapt out we King and I right after work
that day went out and spent a whole
check to go to the Dapper New York club
scene King had a derby on yeah
I was bad I missed out that picture
y'all took was ew okay continue and that
club scene was crazy you go to Palladium
they had Palladium has literally like
grandstand seating where you could sit
you could watch like whatever crazy
anime they had on screen they had people
dancing in cages they had all kinds of
wild stuff and Shaq was just had his
birthday party there and we rolled up on
Happy Birthday Brothers No Doubt thanks
for coming y'all you know much love and
that that's the time before cell phone
so nobody had a camera
that's what dude celebrities could be
low back in the day
I'm sitting at the table and we're
having a good time we have bottles of
doing what we yeah Shaq got up from his
table it came and said at our table it
was like yeah it would look like your
table was having more fun
yeah man it was it was just one of those
things like
you know I have my bathroom stories see
when you when you go to the bathroom at
the Palladium it's it's uh
put this on the sex with the emphasis
it was a fun time so I know Harold has
some stories to back at it yeah
all right so all right so you heard how
fun the Palladium is right yes and the
Limelight is you know for purveyors of
situations and situations
the tunnel
there's no security checking with you
going in actual everybody in them
is like have armed security
if you understand what I'm saying and
the fact that Harold is there
Harold is demonstrative in size it's not
a giant dude but Harold is there moving
and shaking with the element is thug
element yeah bro and he's moving through
New York city so I'm telling you who he
is shows you how layered and diverse he
is yes we need him back because we only
gave you a small yeah those are just
yeah that ain't even a full spectrum
like there's so much to him that we
didn't get a chance to touch but uh you
haven't salute to him when I salute to
that story
that program bar on the progress bar on
the screen isn't for factsies it's for
little Timmy's operation please save it
hopefully little Timmy can make it that
little Timmy became a thing last week it
was it was out there
in the Twitter
then we got snowball backslap member for
two years five dollar Super Chat out of
respect for Lance the destiny truth
bombs will be at a minimum yo
um that that was kind of it was oh man
that was weird I can't even UH 60 years
old have they said what happened oh man
but I look back at it and I was like man
I love this man's career you know he's
in John Wick he's over here he's over
there and he just became a very uh small
integral part of everything that we kind
of did as far as you know HBO The Wire
yes you know uh then to Destiny type of
stuff it was he was there in little
aspects for us and the thing is that he
was like he's not that dude that you
like he disappears into a role you hear
the voice through that science ready
like he's Lance Reddick in every role
Zavala his last Riddick as well no it's
just Lance Reddick as last readic but
that was the charm of him it was like
you know that voice and it doesn't
matter even like when he did it with an
accent in the John Wick movies like it
doesn't mean it's last readic Quantum
break I remember
people don't know your man has some
spots that he's in he's been in a lot of
games yeah
I just 60 years old brother that's right
oh that's too young we got to take care
of ourselves man for sure all right then
we have Joe Repco AKA flame love that's
finest member for 29 months Lord bronze
good afternoon fellas hope you're all
doing well this weekend my heart still
aches over the loss of Lance Reddick
Gone Too Soon rest in peace to the
legend absolutely absolutely absolutely
so with the flame on that no nick said
now we need a weekly podcast featuring
King and Saul discussing their clubbing
Adventures
I have no desire to be in divorce court
again thank you
[Laughter]
good luck
Robert Kelly Super Chat amazing
interview Lawrence Harold is a legend
yeah he is kind of Beyond The Legend
like he's icon
that's it okay we are caught up oh cool
did you get no no um oh we got oh yeah
Dad mod gaming five dollars for chatting
happy Sunday Lord's about to sit down
the Sunday dinner with the fam we'll
catch this episode later tonight have a
great Sunday around thank you
um were you able to get what are your
questions in to the uh to Harold so we
was able to get that off and I think it
was it yeah we got a force okay yeah
let's hit that like listen that like
those likes it was like yeah man we got
to get into it um before actually before
we get into the actual
um next time you had a pole and we have
something else if you want to do it now
you want to do it later let's do it now
okay
let's do it now
guys
you don't have to answer it please don't
answer this thing how do you feel when
you get a deal do you feel smart do you
feel lucky do you feel like I tend to
feel all of these things smart lucky
excited because I always feel like I'm
getting over a little bit and in the
world where we have a lot of inflation
yeah any little help is important so
that's why today's episode is sponsored
by honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or your computer thanks to
Honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds your cart let me tell
you how it works so imagine that you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
you go to checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons
you wait a couple of seconds ask honey
searches for coupons that it can find
for your site if it finds a working
coupon you watch the prices drop it is
that simple that is it so for me you
know a couple of weeks back I said I
like to use it when I purchase food on
the weekends because there is no cooking
in my house on the weekends the past
couple of weeks though I've been using
it to purchase little Nicks and knacks
that I need for our trip to PAX East
now as the Lord's note PAX East is one
of those places where it is imperative
that you have comfortable sneakers to
walk around in because you're going to
be on your feet for a very long time so
I need a new pair of comfortable
sneakers I went found what I needed
put it in the uh in the checkout box and
immediately honey jumped in and said hey
we found a couple of coupons that can
work for your purchase I saved almost 18
on my sneaker purchase and now I'm going
to be comfortable with packs and knowing
that I saved some money on it so that to
me and it's it's the easiest thing in
the world to use it really is it just
pops up you have it installed and that's
all it is once you shop for anything
online it will find some sort of
discount for you that is awesome so
let me tell you some things you might
not know about honey so it just doesn't
work on your desktop right it works on
your iPhone too all you have to do is go
in activate it on Safari and you save on
the go and that's it right so the truth
of the matter is if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out and by getting it you're
going to be doing yourself a solid as
well as supporting your favorite podcast
so in order to show support I need you
guys to get go to get PayPal honey for
free and go to joinhoney.com slash Iron
Lords I repeat that is join honey.com
slash Iron Lords
yo I'm sorry it was the it was okay
that was sad oh hey Sam do you use honey
or let us play with each other yo I
can't I can't with y'all I can't with
y'all messy
yeah yeah
the link is in the description thank you
very much you can use honey for whatever
you need thank you very much exactly the
description y'all please follow that you
know as we pay the bills you know what
I'm saying shout out to Honey shout out
to honey you already know it's lots of
the cops right now going by us it's very
very active
um Yoda chat is wow funny he's like stop
why you ain't use the soft voice why are
you ain't saying that I know saw voices
if you can't we can't you know people
you know so the soft voice was a little
bit too low for the foot for the mic
last time
no no no so anyway let's get into last
week's poll opposal to end the people
I've spoken with the latest delay off
star field falling out of the next 12
months decree from the Xbox and Bethesda
2022 showcase which to you is most
important the winner of our three-way
ILP poll at 56 of the vote was the soft
talk Sunday Lords star Fields quality
and polish should be number one priority
as Xbox most important exclusive since
Halo Group coming in at second place
with 33 of the vote was the gangster
list Lords Xbox stop over promising and
under delivering your word should mean
something group can camera turned on
because I said that
and in last place with a 10 of the vote
was I don't care God Howard gotta saved
little Timmy so shout out to all those
who wrote in the vote um King uh the
soft talk Lords outside thought
um I was at the urinal
Wow
when he said he was going to go up for
urinal break nobody for TMI so it's not
even specified
obviously he wasn't going in the corner
he said can he take a pee break do you
want me to be as blunt as this
all right so
um
so could you recap what the soft talk
news one real quick sorry all right so
the soft talk dude said
um 56 of the vote was starfield's
quality and polish should be number one
priority as Xbox most important
exclusives right all right so listen
um you guys that keep coming from me
like I'm not saying that that's not a
priority yes that is the priority I'm
talking about the letter of the law
dudes like people don't understand that
me holding them accountable
for having 30 Games there and only 10 of
these games did not ship
or has a date and those are the 10 most
those are the most ten wanted games
right so that means that your show
should have been a two to be honest with
you and then the fact that you over
promising and under delivering that is
not my fault and I should not say oh I
should not have to choose quality over
shipping time right shouldn't have never
boxed yourself in that corner y'all
gonna get this work because that's what
y'all did but again quality of the game
is of the utmost importance that is
probably the most important aspect of it
so yeah put you back to September no I
don't care you could push it back to
September all you like my thing is you
should have never gave yourself that
date anyway to block yourself in yeah
right and then you're not gonna have me
tell you how you guys gave yourself an L
this was unnecessary that's like walking
in the room and saying you know what I
feel like stubbing my toe today slam
your toe into the wall you don't need to
do these things things if you get it to
yourself and you're going to get the
smoke now had you not said anything and
the game came out in September we all
would be happy right but now you got
some undue criticism that you didn't
need to have and now you got it but the
game is of the utmost importance and it
it does look 60 frames now opposed to
that 30 when it was Todd ready it was
Todd ready
now I'm actually I'm impressed King
impressed with you analysis
yeah I agree with that though it's just
it's just the unnecessary rake because
you you put limitations on yourself that
you know
you don't necessarily have control over
it that's the thing like if you have
ultimate control over something and you
know it's gonna come out when you say
it's gonna cool but you don't have that
control and you know what and the thing
is Xbox is not in a position where they
have enough good will
to do that to do that to do that and
keep getting away with it without
negative narratives being so so the
prominent talking and it's just like
don't do it to yourself just don't do it
to yourself but whatever again we'll see
about September we'll see
that September it might slip it could
very well happen yeah he's on oh wow see
y'all are not really hearing him when he
talks because I heard him when he said
I'm not even confident in the September
6th and
me it wasn't even about you know about
them shipping then it was it was just
really about the blatant lies that was
on stage yeah don't do that don't just
do it just
just spit because and
it's on there
now when anybody
burnt man on this right probably you
know she didn't probably want to go
along with that but 12 months was a
great estimate for certain things to
happen but you're not in control of a
lot of moving parts right right as far
as you know stalker too you know that
game not sure
you're not in control of these things
but that's a good point you know uh
these are the games for the foreseeable
future right and you gave yourself a
lockdown of 12 months that's that's not
good little Timmy didn't make it bro
yeah and to be fair a lot of those games
have made it and and some a few more
will make it before whatever the June
deadline they put on themselves yeah but
the important in this what this is where
Optics matter the important thing is
that at this point at least one of your
games isn't making it and maybe two
right and that's where again
absolutely no need no doubt we we have
beaten it to death but we got them um
that came in yeah we got a couple more
okay so we got black boxing Kings five
dollar Super Chat salute to the iron
Lords podcast I got Kayla plan over
David Benavides okay all right okay
being that I'm not gonna do a combat
show uh combat talk that day but me and
Saul probably do that'll be dope me and
Saul couldn't be able to do something uh
for you he's probably record it right
there listen there's a possibility that
a Kayla plant can't beat them Caleb
plant has the ability the boxing ability
the movement of footwork and uh hand
speed the problem with Caleb plant is he
dips to his left and he leaves his head
exposed uh David benavidez is a tall
Orthodox fighter he will jab his way in
and he's not afraid to let his hands go
at the detriment of his defense here but
his offense is so Superior and he's so
bigger and stronger than uh Kayla plant
that the oven hand right will be coming
down if he gets hit with the overhand
right at least two times in a round you
can see a concussion state will happen
and he will be able to knock out Kayla
plant now I'm going to say this anytime
you take in a bigger Man versus a
smaller man and they both have
comparable skill sets the bigger man
always win unless the smaller guy is
Floyd yeah
[Laughter]
I got David benavidez probably by late
round Knockout by 11th frown hopefully
it doesn't happen my heart wants Caleb
plant but uh Batman always told me never
bet with your heart always bet with your
head absolutely
we have Lord Metroid two dollar Super
Chat the Palladium toilets podcast with
King and Son
super late oh here's some stuff down in
the bathrooms
a lot of bathroom conversations bro
remember we went to the vinyl
Club there was it was it was three no it
was four levels high and each floor had
a different like thing one was house the
one was hip hop hip hop one was uh
exactly
I'm not lying yo yeah it was it was some
real head banging stuff going on there
and you had to get through you had to
get through that to get to your next
you had to walk through the madness to
get to get to it was like Bruce Lee Game
of Death
it's like seafood yeah
yeah it was again this is this could
definitely be a patreon
you have to pay for that yeah
all right who else do we having well we
got oh man dingo big Dickens five dollar
Super Chat wait something seems off we
can't quite put my finger on it I think
the cream is missing from all the black
coffee
where you at bro yo why he had to put it
like that too
yeah you can just say yo I missed my bro
at it
Super Chat Hal deserves the industry
icon award at the BGA is for sure that
would be yes oh by the way uh Jeff
keigley was in the building but we was
there yes in a hoodie Jeff was low but
he was there at the New York game awards
he was there um
what was what you know what I'm saying I
don't know though yeah a lot of people
yeah we have to talk to him because we
we need him to to squeeze the arm of a
certain other uh you know bro
I ran down on him I ran down him and I
was just like yo you know I mean he he
he he's he's probably too discussion but
yeah he's a busy man but he is a busy
man I will I run down him a few times
anytime he he wants to have a record
button as well yeah oh yeah hell yeah
yeah
listen all y'all watching right now
thinking oh yeah I just give him the
excuse I can't do it on Sunday we
haven't recorded
he was trying to let y'all understand
now that we gotta understand it continue
I understood
here we have black boxing Kings two
dollar Super Chat panel 305 Sweet Pea
babies
that's a good friend too yeah man this
is me so um yeah man um Diablo first of
all real quick um anybody you gotta say
it like jazz quartet oh yeah beautiful
Diablo
no no I have not played it but if
anybody want gift that to me
yeah
I just downloaded it and and I it was
late so I couldn't do it I actually got
out of the code though so King if you
need a code I will I don't know how much
time you have today to play it but no I
have a code please send it
I have you know I have ways
to the king it's King David OTW on Xbox
that's my game well no I'll have to it's
a general code and you have to figure
what about
five hours in it I didn't get a chance
to do everything I wanted to do but um
yeah man it really really surprised me
it really is probably atmosphere
absolutely amazing it's real dark like
if Diablo's always dark but like one
thing that impressed me
was like the atmosphere but the voice
acting with the atmosphere and it was
just like that the accents the
townspeople just that it was very like
very like I go supposed to but the game
start off as such a way that I was like
yo Diablo like we got a story now like
we we're drove that opening cinematics
she's wild then it was just like there
was just one part where I was okay the
game got me like you do something and it
tells people's like yeah I'm saying I'm
gonna do that for you we got you
and I'm not gonna spoil it but something
happened and I was like hey yo I know
this game ain't gonna do this to me but
it was such a dark cool thing and I was
just like yo this game is
game it was just Wow first time at um
Diablo nah I'm a newcomer obviously
three I've seen two but I didn't really
play it three I played three I played a
lot you know saying I really like it but
it like the thing about this one that I
like is that they actually in my opinion
because look I played them before but I
never really cared about
it doesn't I've never really it never
really it was just our eyes demons his
craziness is ah you know what I'm saying
like this excuse me you just went in for
the loot yeah I'll be here for your
looter your Co-op the addiction the fun
the builds okay I get this piece of this
chest with city jobs with this power and
then I'm there for the skill trees oh
the world I'm for the game play I'm
never you never really listen to
whatever the story no it just not even a
necromancing one it just I don't know
what it was their story just never
connected with me I was just like all
right I'm just here just tell me who to
kill next
joint yeah shout out to people I did
miss out on Diablo 2 and a lot of people
did say Diablo 2 was where it was at so
this to me if Diablo 2 feel like that
this is definitely that energy like this
world is brooding it is it is it is very
depressing it is you got the super very
cold area you got you know what I'm
saying caves the evil truck like it is
such atmosphere and personality so I
started off I went I went sorcerer for
the first I usually don't go sorcerer in
these type of games so let me see what
the source looks like normally I pick
Barbarian you know what I'm saying or
you know I might pick a ninja roll type
situation but let me pick the sorcerer
so I had my little
like this electric um this lightning
whip joint up close that are kind of
stunned characters and then I picked
another Power where it's like these
freeze arrows so I can got my little
distance how about like a short range
and I have my distance yo skill trees
very expansive you know what I'm saying
I really have a solver appreciate this
based on all the conversations we've had
recently
um skill trees very expansive and and
the Nuance the minutia of of synergizing
things um the loot really excellent you
know saying I really like um the little
I mean yeah I was always had this but I
always appreciate the little touches
when it's like you put on Armor your
your character you know what I'm saying
you see you chilling you know kind of
thing
um black hair rating black people hair
rating probably three out of five though
you know yeah but he's really small I
mean is a really small
I'm weird on that no I don't I don't
care too
too when I mean I was just happy I saw
dreads I was like all right we got
dreads yeah this option there's better
than nothing but this is you don't play
this game for the Character Creator like
it's not really that but I'll be Salat
salute to them they got the voice acting
they got the voice actors so I thought
the voice actor for you for the main
um what you call protagonist I thought
was interesting um but yeah the
strongest surprise was definitely the
story
um I highly advise people to stay after
the bar scene I would highly advise that
um as far as like the beta itself
obviously we know people
um
had a lot of issues you know kind of
getting into it you know it was I heard
it was really rough was it Friday but I
guess would it drop everybody was
playing I think yeah so I didn't get a
chance some some of the stories I heard
of the wait times were like crazy so I I
didn't jump let me get this yeah okay
please I'm because I'm I'm hearing it
piece by piece yeah I really didn't get
a chance to play with anybody you know
this week uh but
so this is always online yeah we're
going to talk about that when we get to
my Netflix yeah this is always nails to
the nose yeah cause this is my thing
right I get it from a Cooperative
standpoint right the thing that bothered
me is I remember like I I think my food
came or something like I think I ordered
something all right let me just and I'm
Paul I'm looking for pause and I'm like
wait a minute because I'm confused I'm
thinking it's a standard single player I
can just yeah
and it's Elden ring
my characters screaming and I had an NPC
with me he's like yeah brother they're
fighting me I'm like what is going on I
had to go save my character then move
him into like a house that nobody could
bother him for a little bit so yeah I
didn't like that for especially for the
single player I was like wow so yeah
that that always online joint um another
nitpick is all right so the camera is
kind of zoomed in a little closer than
most Diablos and it looks good it don't
get me wrong but sometimes like you're
questing and then like they'll have the
yellow Little Star and they tell you you
know that's where you got to go for your
next objective kind of thing and then
like I just wish sometimes you could
pull back the camera a little bit I
didn't see the option to pull back the
camera a little bit to kind of search
and then the mini map is ain't really
helping that in that respect so
basically what you got to do what I was
doing was like all right let me hit
select so to speak go to map all right
where I gotta go to kind of find you
know what I'm saying where I gotta you
know kind of with that objective is so
again that was just a little nitpick so
it's not
um as far away as Diablo 2 Diablo 3
style is a little bit closer than it
felt a little closer to me now
graphically it looks good because of
that and you can really see more details
and then they'll switch a little camera
angle sometimes when they do when
they're doing more narrative and stuff
like that and a couple of little bitty
you know in-game kind of cinematic stuff
but I just felt like there were times
where I did need like I'm Traverse into
a big town right and I could tell this
steps leading to a castle there's a
party was like can I pull back a little
bit so I can see where I'm going what's
what's ahead of me you know what I'm
saying kind of thing and I didn't feel
they had that but again you know maybe
it's the beta hopefully they they have
maybe when you uh pair up with more
people then do a scale back so you can
see the whole group yeah
um I gotta see it because of capital
looks I'm gonna like that camera during
PVP maybe so you know I'm saying I just
felt like they do I feel it's a little
bit of issues with it it's so pulled in
I mean graphic looks nice but sometimes
I do want it to pull out and um yeah the
minimap didn't really help that so that
was that collection wise
um
I actually had a fairly good experience
most of the time I played only had one
time watches got completely booted out
and I was like damn and then they kind
of remembered what was the last
checkpoint I had to do so I did like One
Mini thing over it was like a small
little Quest I wasn't running too crazy
but I could see how that could get
annoying you know what I'm saying if you
know there's there's consistent arrows
there I saw the world tier Joy so
probably like a level eight to ten or
something like that they had the clan
setup system you could do that I want to
do it my next session which hopefully
today I wouldn't do it with people so if
can you get down let me know
um I'm always ready yeah because I
definitely want to try try it um once
once the iron bank approves the
situation um I would definitely like to
try it with people to see the
traditional experience but if let's it
feels good I have to admit overall
the game feels I might have to hold my
my iron bike choice for that Resident
Evil 4. oh no look you got to make a
decision yeah I don't know I don't know
because my back is against the wall yeah
I'm with you know uh yeah no rest ABK
deal to go through yeah you know I think
you you yeah you go you go ahead I mean
again like I said the the I can get you
the beta code yeah
I mean he said it though he said for
what I like out there
I got to be Discerning yeah you know um
well contrary to what you people might
believe you know we're not rolling in
the cash
my choice uh from the iron bank will
have to be very discernible so it's
based on a couple of uh criteria and APK
seems to be making it over to Microsoft
so in turn
Rod Ferguson just could not say anything
[Laughter]
sitting there on the side so uh yeah
I'll be waiting for this oh okay I see I
see we do it but look I will say
thoroughly impressed and the addiction
start and I'm like there's a pottery so
I'm like they cast off early true
because I would have had to make a tough
decision like it is really good they
taking it back to the essence again
story on the gameplay Luke feels there I
want to blast that out I want to get to
level 25 I'm thinking they said the um
some progress or some stuff does take
over and um I want to test out
apparently there's like a world
boss thing going on that's super hard
that I want to see if I get a part of on
that but yeah do you think that um it's
always online stuff is for the PC dude
for the DRM I don't know I don't know
like I mean this is remember this is the
first time that the Diablo's coming out
on all platforms at the same time right
so again it's it's trying to keep I mean
it's the reality of a game in in this
day and age like it was always going to
be that as long as I don't have that
storefront stuff they were messing up
with with Diablo 3 again that's that's
my biggest word always online stuff
again yeah it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to me that if you just can't
have a fully offline experience and do
that but um I mean I get it I kind of
get it but yeah I mean this is this is
this this should be Diablo's biggest
launch ever yeah man as big as Diablo 2
was as as much as people like Diablo 3
as well the idea of going back to a
Diablo 2-esque experience darker
um with all like the modern sort of
bells and whistles that you would hope
an improvement over Diablo 3 is this is
I think this game's gonna be big that
um Starfield was ready for June
and uh being because I I see 60 frames
per second in this latest trailer so um
thank God they got more time yeah yeah I
don't think they're too much is gonna do
anything
I will I will stress once again it seems
60 but I mean if it was always going to
be it it's always gonna be 60 on PC
there's no way you're gonna give a PC
player yes game right and it just felt
like they were still playing on PC like
if you show me the car to me if you're
showing if you have 60 running on
Console you make sure to show that this
is like an awesome game
I hope so I'm just I'm just saying let
me get my point get your body
Diablos seems to have kicked us certain
guy across the rooms because they're
giving them two months to breathe
do you think that is it more so than you
know anything else with starford because
it doesn't make any sense but if you say
we're going to let uh because y'all was
coming at me Diablo King now like the
hell with Diablo
but if we get in Diablo and it's in Game
Pass that's a huge boom I mean I don't
know guys please enlighten me I mean
sorry I was gonna jump here yeah go
ahead jump in no I mean look
you know third-party partners are part
of the game right third-party
Partnerships out again so they want to
be respectful of their Partners No Doubt
I don't know in this case you know say
it's like it it I will give you this it
is tricky because even though let's rise
of the other building right so he gotta
talk from a blizzard perspective a
separate so when he makes statements
saying hey you know we have no plans on
this in Game Pass that's what you're
supposed to say as a separate company
when you had no intentions of a deal
happening right but then on the same
token you have Phil when they talk to
him about okay future of Activision
Blizzard kick if the deal goes through
you know yeah this is a game Diablo will
be a targeted game that we would put
into you know Game Pass kind of thing so
I look at it as that
I just look at his attack which stuff I
look at it as a Todd Howard fluid
situation thing you let us know how much
time you need when it's ready you let us
know and hey if it's it's doing great if
not it's going to be September so that's
that's pretty much how I take it I do
feel ultimately though it does benefit
both games in that sense because it
gives Diablo the it's going to be a huge
release like let's just say
hypothetically if the deal was done
could you imagine once if the deal gets
done Diablo in Game Pass is
arguably bigger than anything since Call
of Duty like it's it's it is the perfect
game pass game yep four-player Co-op
then it's not yeah it's graphical but
think about like you can have multiple
Platforms in the the cross play action
cross-platform across play aspects just
intermingling easily right then they
have you play the game they got all
these little social features to be able
to talk to people without talking to
people and stuff like that so
yeah I mean this is a huge just a huge
release for Xbox Microsoft paid close
attention to this they make no mistake
but so what do you think you know
reference to the king's question
you made it you made it too
sorry yes
I always I always go back to 2021 and
you know the decision to kind of drop
the mo the Halo multiplayer right when
you know Forza is just having its moment
and you know my thinking at the time was
like nah it's all Game Pass it's all
additive the crossover isn't as big like
yeah you could do it and the fact of the
matter is that it doesn't matter if it's
in in a service or not um it's not
always additive these games need their
time to breathe they need their moment
in the sun
um they just do right so to the point of
you know it be it could it possibly
being a thing where you listen let's
move over let this game breathe so that
you have your time to breathe as well
because we do think this this deal is
going to go through and it's going to be
a real consideration that we have to
make that's a possibility but I you know
I always go back to you know a bgs game
you can always use more work
it's just the fact that you say hey man
like if you want to push it down the
line a couple of more months to to add
extra polish the op the option is there
cool if I'm tired I'm taking them I bet
you know what yeah why not
um regardless of the state the game is
in because it's just the nature of that
type of game like it's so many systems
so much to to think about and Diablo is
that when you look at Starfield right
Starfield still is the single player
selfish you know RPG Diablo is something
that on its own is a movement you put it
in Game Pass yeah or player co-op
you know you put you know across game
plus console and Game Pass PC in
addition to every other platform that's
coming onto yeah it's massive and it's
and
it's going to have the Zeitgeist moment
for a while so you don't want to have
that overlap with with Starfield
possibly taking some of that Thunder or
or the the hopefully not the situation
where Starfield comes in is
underwhelming compared to a Diablo 4 and
then we have a different narrative that
in and of itself would be unfair as well
right so nah give him the time give them
the time even if it's a business
decision if it's just the way it
happened to happen or if it's none of
those things and it just needed more
time I think the the idea of stacking
stuff in Game Pass though I believed in
it before I don't think it flies because
I think the Zeitgeist moment still
exists people only have so much
bandwidth to play you know x amount of
games at the same time so if they do
feel like they're different types of
games you'd be surprised how much
overlap there is between you know Gamers
and the types of games they like to play
I got a free phone across
so we blame Diablo for Little Timmy
until we got something on his way out
though man
look man you was a tough mom for Timmy
but he smiled with that one he's smiling
with that he goes out
is that a Game Pass blue Timmy dying in
vain we got something he got something
to play yeah man he spent all his money
in Game Pass he don't got no money
it is interesting I'm noticed it in a
little debate in the challenge how y'all
feel about the whole when I mentioned
that you know the single player appears
to be online you know to my knowledge
right now how do you guys feel about
that see some people like yo no excuse
what do you got what y'all at with that
I don't like that um
yeah I don't like it at all I don't like
it you know I I get it because you know
when you a game that big when you look
at past launches of Diablo games like
there's a lot of stuff gonna be broken
and just just on server-side stuff right
because you know like like we've seen in
the beta test
servers get clogged up quick because
people won't believe this yeah yeah and
and you have to you have to already be
prepping for that right the beta test as
apart from being a beta test for the
gameplay itself you know and whatever
the systems it is uh pause
it's to see how much how hard to load ah
yeah you're gonna stress that low you
stressed out slow pause pause
so what you're saying is
they trying to fill it up to see how
much y'all can take
oh man man that's one way to put it
that's one way to put it that's one way
they're trying to break it oh man
they put pressure put pressure on it
yes it hasn't to me it's as much it's as
much testing the servers is that oh yeah
that's that's what I'm saying the beta
boys has tested that load
in high school I was I was in the choir
right and me and my roommate were in the
choir and um so you know we singing
these songs or whatever and there's one
particular song that we could never get
through without dying laughing and the
choir director hated us for it because
we we sang pretty well we had decent
voices but it was just like we we always
you know it was always a pause moment
this song this is how it went I opened
my mouth to the Lord
and I won't turn back
I will go I shall go to see what the end
is going to be I know I could never yo
when we had this thing that for a
performance we would just we would mouth
it and not say okay
bro
yeah oh man wow
man I'm not cool with your lyrics
who wrote this R Kelly
would give it up
with the Illuminati
the rock is
as well so and this is just going to be
the nature of it if you want this is the
thing if you really want an experience
across all platforms that is going to be
easily sort of updated and Bug fixes and
stuff like that you need this right yeah
you need this you can't have really have
bespoke systems you have to have a
pipeline that works across all versions
of the game so to me it makes sense uh
for as as big as this game is is going
to be so I get it you know I'd rather
just be able to not be online and play
by myself or whatever but yeah whatever
you you can play by yourself and still
be online and that's the nature you know
this isn't 2013 when you know Xbox is
saying you know you know always online
whatever constantly being checked you
know your the connectors watching you
whatever it's just the nature of the
business at this point so whatever it is
what it is yeah no like I said I I you
know again it's unfortunate yes I would
definitely love a dedicated a single
player mode but um
I already know I already know oh it's
back oh okay we're gonna get it but I
just thought that on just in conclusion
like I said I think they got a beggar I
think they definitely got it it's it's
Lilith she's the I think the daughter
Buffet stole you know what I'm saying
and then like the classes look dull I
think they they didn't let us play all
the classes that we played sorcerer
they got a new they got some Druid joint
they don't let me I want to pick the
Druid I wanted to see what he had like
this wolf Joy he had the two wolves
without me look yeah yeah I get a joint
they had the Sorceress which I picked
the Necromancer was available but they
let you pick it in the beta and uh I
think so Barbarian Rogue and sorceress
with sorcerer was available available
yeah right and the other two were not
for the for the beta but um yeah it got
that Vibe it got that energy I think
it's going to be a smash but they
obviously they're gonna figure out more
of the server issues but again my issues
that or that's from Saturday it was I
was getting in I was getting now people
are talking about on PC there's some DC
I heard different beasts on on series X
on console for the most part it was
smooth I just had one disconnect so you
know all this is the stress test and all
that beta boy right you know what I'm
saying kind of thing but that's what I
got on that I did want to touch briefly
on the addicts topic which he had about
all Castlevania you want to just get
we got Galveston with the 20 stupid chat
I have a feeling that the always online
is because of the console players in D3
where they don't have always online for
consoles there's massive cheats for
season play trading is allowed on PC
only wishing you well at Pax thanks but
I appreciate that that is true that is
another consideration about the you know
the PC the sheistiness of the PC
community and whatever and I think they
need to be monitored I don't trust
um I agreed agree you know they're the
Shady underbelly when it comes to video
games
because they they're a fascist group
they are fashions
they're trying they're trying to take
over our communities so we have to we
have to shun them
yeah
download the Metro
fatal boys we're testing their joystick
pressure
whoa whoa whoa when I read that
whoa sir the first thing that popped in
my mind was
[Music]
that
follow me because I didn't call pause
when I said that mouth did pause yeah
then we got we knew this is
new here we go
let's play with each other's joysticks
ten dollars Super Chat I'm late but
here's my petition for a solo song
podcast about his unisex restroom
Adventures whoa
look at this I always use my head oh wow
wow yo this is different this is a
surprise
yeah someone's really really excited
about those stories oh my goodness oh I
want to let y'all guys know we are
closer to that goal than you guys think
because we have to add in the Volari
pillows uh
and purchased those volarisons a lot of
you guys in the chat yes you're
definitely down
um I say oh I can't wait uh Villari is
going to be at Pax thing going on with
them
oops these pillows are shipping out now
so we add that total to that I think
we're closer to uh what is it 75 80
percent and yeah to be honest with you
so anything that we can push this is our
last podcast except for RNR with the
Lords on Tuesday hopefully that's done
automatic show won't be this week
because Wednesday we will be at Pax uh
this Sunday won't be a a thing but
that's right no IOP next Sunday IOP next
Sunday so there's no chance to you know
help us get the facts but uh if whatever
super chats happen today and hopefully
super chats will happen on Tuesday that
will definitely go to that
um anybody that's in the past area we
encourage you guys to come out and say
what's up yo shake hands kiss babies all
that great stuff let's just let me let
me take care of this it's like yo where
the pillow at bro you ain't see the tree
I'm putting it to you right now for
Laurie put the Tweet out you seeing them
constructed you seeing them made so
right now April is looking good we will
get you down this is a long process the
loan process and you know finally shout
out to Volaris
yeah the realm needed to see that you
know obviously we appreciate the trust
that you guys give us to to support yeah
and the patience and the patience it's
not a nursing pillow yeah you guys put
comments on the Facebook joint on the
materials that this thing is made out of
facts this is no cat I'm telling you
like this is a premium situation there's
different textures from head to head the
stitching is completely different yeah
and again embroidering is different the
clip-on in the back when it goes around
your waist is different you know um
IOP here this is a different thing and
it doesn't lose that cushion like I'm
using it and it doesn't lose it so
definitely check it out I'm telling you
you will love it and if you got one
already get one for your girlfriend now
for sure you're gonna steal this one
from me 100 we'll put in the chat again
use Lord 15 a lot of people are picking
them up they're not using the Lloyd's
discount so make sure I just use Lord 15
I put that in there you know what I'm
saying so make sure y'all use that when
y'all picking them up but y'all can see
it but I'll put also the link in the
description for valari themselves
showing the making of it you already
know it what's going on check out Lords
of gaming.net from Wednesday on yes well
no Thursday on really really Thursday
actually actually Wednesday on Wednesday
Wednesday on Wednesday there's there's
some things there's some things
on a drop-in day
Wednesday on because normally we don't
do this there is there is some
pre-recorded things
other things other things you are good
on content sir you relax relax
I know I just got in my feet ain't even
touch the ground yeah
oh definitely from Wednesday on to
Saturday it's going to be packed with
information and let me tell you little
known Secret
yeah
wow anyway exactly move it over but uh
yeah I just want to get this real quick
from um okay because this is technically
part of the same topic because that
particularly yeah no no if it's take if
it's part of him because even those
Diablo addicts topic was was Castlevania
yeah I just wanted to get his bars off
on Castlevania so there is a rumor
um shout out to um video games Chronicle
on this one uh it says new Konami
trademark could refer to Castlevania so
they said that uh Konami has filed a
trademark and said which is uh for the
phrase project Zircon was Sir Khan
excuse me was applied for last week and
published the uh trademark assault for
use at a large number of fields
including software for commercial video
game machines and is noted by jimitsu
um that uh Zircon may be referenced to
an item found in the Castlevania series
or card is a jewel that is provided
several Castlevania games and first made
its appearance in Castlevania Symphony
of the Night so yeah this this is a you
know rumor going on it could be it could
not be where you at now some you are a
huge Symphony of the Night you and your
brother Lord kind
um talk to me like how do you feel do
you you know something on the horizon
would you welcome it how you feel about
this news
I'm excited that it's coming back right
and hopefully in sort of multiple
iterations you know
from the the Netflix show I was just
like man this Castlevania is so good it
deserves to be back you know as a game
where where it began and you know seeing
this dead cells uh Castlevania uh add-on
is is just really again gave me the itch
I recently not too long ago got the uh
Castlevania Advanced collection on
switch
um that you know it put together all the
Gay Boy Advance games which are amazing
games in one package
um so yeah I'm a Castlevania stand and
when you start when you start talking
you know in the vein of one of the goats
alongside Symphony of the Night is a
game that today is still perfect because
you know the art style everything about
it it didn't doesn't really age you know
it's it's one of those things that aids
is like fine wine you don't need to
really necessarily improve it maybe you
could make it a little prettier but it's
already pretty enough so
um to see it come back is exciting to my
worry it's just I don't know what kind
of development capacity
Konami proper has anymore right are
these are these deals with uh you know
with other development Studios to get
games off the ground are they doing some
of this internally is it a little bit of
both right
um but I'm excited that they care about
it again and they're coming back to the
table we're hearing that some of the
stuff could be actually like a reboot of
the whole series is it going to be a
reboot in the 2D vein are they going to
try to go back to the well with like
sort of Lords of Shadow and try to do a
3D thing as well so it's just exciting
they're talking Castlevania again and
you know to me
I love both so I could loads of Shadow
one was a really good game right it was
it it tried to take the best of of 2D
Castlevania and and you know implement
it in the 3D space wasn't always
successful but but it but it but it it
was better than you know Castlevania 64
and stuff like that the other you know
sort of 3D iteration so to me this is
exciting to see I just I I really I
would love to know internally at Konami
since they have kind of stopped making
games what is their development capacity
internally or are they just sort of
Licensing this stuff out to to Great
hopefully the great Studio to get these
games made so exciting nonetheless shout
out to Big Pepito or fungu he's I think
he bet solved you should play blood
stain ritual of the night oh yeah of
course I played that eager baby you got
played that actually he was just
checking your credentials and and the
and the the 8-Bit versions too to the
little those no doubt um you're a king a
person who's introduced me to many a
Castlevania remember going to the crib
um
blood oh my God that soundtrack greatest
oh my God
uh Castlevania ever you're right I don't
want to interrupt you one quick second
though even though this Castlevania is
not lauded as one of the best one of my
favorite memories from you is being
introduced to Super Castlevania oh my
God and I remember the Whip and the way
the scale and the thing would rotate I
remember the music
I was like yo that's what you I think
that was part of that whole Super
Nintendo rollout Supercar rollout you
did and I looked at my Genesis so
sideways when I came back from your
project you know when Genesis tried to
do that Castlevania that's a great
Castlevania but it's Bloodlines no buddy
anytime
no okay
it isn't it isn't the show piece that
Castlevania 4 is but as it came not kids
yeah the music the music wasn't on Paul
[Laughter]
I came from greatness I came from the
Super Nintendo Castlevania that sound
chip was Spain
that first beat was crazy
I said the battle's over yeah
and then it didn't then came Genesis
they sound chip was exposed at that time
it looked good his kneecaps wasn't right
yeah I remember the crackly hadouken
Championship
you right you right that was the like
genesis that's what you see you start to
show his age Super Nintendo came out
after but I remember like the hard girl
kid was a little roughly Gravelly yeah
they sound you started because
music yeah when I find out turbo
Graphics can hang with them yes so my my
drink was ravando of of oh my God what
turbo duel oh my God that that literally
took it to the next level all right so
let's go
Castlevania being an IEP I really don't
want it to go 2D right
um I like the 3D tries I thought that
they gave up on it because the 3D space
that we had at that time isn't mature
right but I think now it is after
playing some of the the
um Darksiders and using the whip in that
space uh you know hopefully the the new
Indiana Jones that's coming out uses the
whip in a good space I think we are at a
mature State when it comes to 3D gaming
and I would like for them to like go
back to it you could have elements of
the 2D board with the 3D worlds
looking like you know because before our
thing was Parallax scrolling oh yeah
yeah no
seeing the multi-levels of the clouds
and stuff in the background moving at
the same time the foreground is moving
to give you a 3D type feel yeah a 2d 3D
uh feel so hopefully they can
encapsulate all of that like Sav said
maybe they have a good developer using
it because we haven't heard really too
much from uh Konami proper you know um
we felt that uh as soon as this guy left
uh the company it really like he really
took a galvanized most of the talent
going with him so hopefully this is
being done well hopefully it's also not
a PlayStation exclusive
yeah that's another thing there is yeah
that you know there is that relationship
the last thing I heard the last thing I
heard uh with the metal gear stuff was
that these are things that PlayStation
sacked up now maybe they're suppressing
them now because of the ABK deal that's
you know looming in the background in
the court round courtrooms and Microsoft
holding games off of the PlayStation
when in reality this Castlevania being
brought up
is one of the titles along with that
metal gear uh remake that is supposed to
be locked behind a PlayStation a wall
Garden
um
being that this is probably a
four-year-old uh
talk a conversational rumor now they TM
this thing
it might be closer to release
I think honestly it could be still a
PlayStation thing I think that's kind of
why we don't have full disclosure on
what's going on with it or what it looks
like okay yeah we got to see we got to
see
um you know hey I I'm always down you
know I'm saying for another Castlevania
regardless the series still kicking and
just want to see what type of iteration
3D what do you want I mean
not bad either way to be honest I mean
because I know the purists solve no I I
I I I I could since again the first Lord
of The Shadow was really good I enjoyed
it
um I you know you can do both yeah
just bring it back just bring it back
I'm I'm open to whatever whatever they
want to go with it just just bring it
back it's it's a very iconic franchise
and I like to see it still continue to
live on and you know I need my trademark
music I need you know the good battles
and all that good stuff see where you
know give me that Darkness give me that
give me that you know
yeah I would really love the thing about
bringing it back in 2D right it's like
you really need you need people that are
skilled at 2D art Sprite work right like
that the ideal thing is to make it not
you know again
you know bloodstain was was was great
but it had like a look to it where it
was like you know kind of 2D a little
bit it's kind of 2D 3D you know polygons
I would really love uh you know somebody
just to take the time and the effort and
I and hand-drawn Sprites oh really like
that would be amazing okay okay but I I
know that's you know maybe they don't
think it's worth it but bro
no doubt no doubt but that's what I got
32 bit Style 16-bit
see that's the thing though when you
really it's really our our Jam like but
then you see what they did with Symphony
of the Night where it took that right
and and added the horsepower the
PlayStation behind it yeah to really it
was still hand drawn it wasn't 3D like
yeah give him give me give me that
Symphony though give me that Symphony
give give me that level of sprite work
yeah
with all the bells and whistles of the
music whatever give me some crazy Powers
just did the first back Shuffle yeah
and you saw the multiple like you know
there's multiple versions of him oh my
God yeah that's awesome that's when we
was throwing our hands in there for that
PlayStation yeah shout out to Lord Metro
they said vanilla wear whatever yeah
that 2D Sprite work is is kind of crazy
Odin's fear and stuff like that yeah
knows ill yeah man it's just exciting
that it's coming back I'm glad I'm you
know and at this point it's we know that
it is it's kind of a you know that that
Open Secret
so we see trade box is being filed all
that good stuff so yeah so we gotta get
the super chance before we move on to
the next one yeah okay so we have which
one in the library okay we have one bad
mother twenty dollar stupid chat I've
gained more perspective about the gaming
industry whether it be game development
or content creation through IOP that's
in addition to the labs I need on Monday
evening great guest today love all that
you guys do thank you brother appreciate
you absolutely salute and we got let's
play with each other's joysticks two
dollar Super Chat King you're welcome to
join us
I won't say no yeah I got the bathroom
stories what it is is that's that's
y'all thing
and and what I'll do is I'll I'll see my
way out there
you know what a partake no no no this is
me leaving
[Laughter]
[Music]
then we got Captain chats four five five
Super Chat it's not a lot but a little
towards your goal i i a little thanks
for keeping me entertained love you guys
thank you brother much appreciate
everything counts everything everything
it's a little but fast
everything counts
everything we get we take for the
community goes right back into the
podcast I'll see you next time
that we have let's play with each
other's joysticks about to get five
dollars for the chat I see Sav is a fan
of Castlevania I'm also into whips and
biting
maybe the Assam have more in common than
he thought whoa there you go that's
that's riondo of blood right there
yeah so and uh shout out to Tom
Henderson from Insider gaming who was in
the chat earlier maybe still around
uh yeah new report for Tom Henderson uh
indicating that Sony is uh doing a
mid-gen refresh PlayStation upgrade aka
the PS5 Pro
um and that is currently in development
and that uh we already had we already
had news that it was possible that this
coming year we were going to be getting
a uh a detached PS5
disk drive right and they were going to
start making the PS5 digital only with
the option to buy a separate disk drive
if you wanted to have this base games
right and this you know we thought about
this and it's like in a world where
everything is going more digital
where you can see the sales of the
digital games going up you know
exponentially and as especially as
compared to disk based games
so this is something that we expected
but we kind of we never really talked
about the possibilities of this mid-gen
refresh that we saw that were absolutely
necessary last generation I think
um
but this is kind of weird to see now to
be honest with you
um I just I didn't I did not expect this
because both of these machines and I
know King King has other things to say
both of these machines seem like they're
more Cape more than capable to carry a
gen five six maybe even seven years so
what do you guys think about this like
if obviously coming from Tom Henderson
this is a very reliable source I have no
reason to believe this is not the truth
so what do you guys feel about a mid-gen
reef I mean and do you guys feel that
Xbox has one in the works as well and
just hasn't said anything yet kind of
seeing it once this becomes true then we
actually get an announcement of
something which if it's you know if it's
true that it's sometime in 2020 end of
2024 2025 maybe we don't hear about this
for quite some time but
is it something that gamers are going to
react positively to or negatively to and
do you think that Xbox also has
something in the works start with King
where you at with this
okay um
you gave me a lot there
all right so as far as the digital and
detachable thing goes um that's the
option uh definitely I think a
PlayStation C is more that the digital
sales are going that they can get more
money opposed to uh giving out physical
copies where they have to pay us
percentage to the distributor and go
into their Partners like Walmart and
stuff like that but then you know if
Walmart sees them only putting uh
digital consoles out
um that kind of reduces the add-on
purchase buys right because they get
more money by the more stuff that you
add to your purchase as you're walking
out the door if you get a PlayStation
you get a controller you get some wires
you um they make more money off the
wires to be honest with you HBO HDMI
wise and stuff like that
and then you purchase a television or
you purchase more games more stuff that
you purchase the better off it is for
the the retailer right now
if you sell a digital console
that means you're eliminating the add-on
purchase of video games
because those video games will be
purchased right through directly through
the store that's on the box itself so
you don't want to anger them you give an
add-on attachment right so now you get
the plus one sale with the add-on
attachment for those individuals and
then they can probably get some physical
games as well so I believe that's how
they sold it to them that's a
possibility now let's put that to the
side you have research and development
they're worrying about researching in
the development the PlayStation 5 Pro
I think it's kind of redundant and I
don't think it happens
but it has to happen and it makes more
sense for Sony
the PlayStation 4 will always be
the lowest common denominator that they
will always skew to they will always
make games for it so all these games of
services that are coming out
PlayStation already told you that those
games will be on the PlayStation 4. so
how would they be designed would they
designed around the PlayStation 4 and
scaled up to the PlayStation 5 and then
you have the PlayStation 5 Pro that
console will never ever show its true
potential because they always will be
held back by the PlayStation 4 until
they can cut that generation off and
then they will never show the true
potential of the PlayStation 5 Pro
because that will always be held back
from the base PlayStation 5. so these
consoles that are coming out as just
really to show you a different narrative
to just have a different price point you
can't have a peripheral in the store
which is the PlayStation uh 2 VR at a
higher price point than the console
itself because it gives you the false
thought that the peripheral is worth
more than the actual console so you need
to have a console that's in the store
that has a higher price tag than the
peripheral that's outside so that shows
the significance and the power when it
comes to purchasing eyes I think it
comes out I think you never see the true
potential of this thing because of the
PlayStation 4 and I think it only comes
out to push the importance of console
over peripheral because they're not
going to drop the price on a PlayStation
2 VR okay so it's a question do you
think bring out another mid-gen refresh
though elevates what the lowest common
denominator is finally eliminating the
PS4 right I think the PlayStation 4 has
to go but if if you if if you're doing
that then your games or services that
are talented that that that crowd they
don't they're never going to leave that
125 million people behind without giving
them an Avenue to get into these service
based games this is how fortnite is
playable on PlayStation 4 all the way up
to PlayStation 5. right you need to have
it accessible in order to you for you to
get that group now this makes no sense
for Microsoft because the series s
literally pigeonholes you in a spot
where you can escape from right as
brilliant as a series as is you can't do
a mid uh fresh a mid-gen refresh because
one yes series X is not being utilized
at all right now you put out a series X
pro what happens to little man do you
put out a series S pro right so you put
yourself in a box where you can't do any
pros right because you eliminate your
what do what happens to the place the
the Xbox series s base owners well
that's the thing right because the
series asks if you think about it would
they ever upgrade the series s to be as
powerful as the series X and then the X
go up no it doesn't make a whole lot so
it would still be a middle ground
between that where the S and the X are
and that that doesn't feel like a
significant enough jump right
they kind of have they're in a position
where they yeah they they kind of can't
do one they can't do anything
they can't so this is why I tell you and
and I tell everybody yeah the
PlayStation 5 will have a pro because it
will try to put it on Paul with the with
the series X but that's not it because
they're competing without even worrying
about it right the thing is more so they
can have a peripheral in the store that
costs more than a console I think that's
really more their Optics right also
they're still going by old uh metrics
where console sales means more than Sony
than it means to Xbox so having a new
console in the store reigniting the
whole thirst for getting a PlayStation
at that point in time pushes console
sales so they can actually put those
numbers in front of the public because
they use the old metrics again I still
don't think it's going to be a
PlayStation 6 nor a Next Generation Xbox
and I know that's contrary to whatever
Phil Dominus Maximus really is instead
or whatever Sony says yeah they're gonna
have research and development but these
consoles are held back by three years
right because of covet now we're going
to finally start seeing games taken
advantage of Our Generation now so now
the generation starts now right and then
you go seven years from that point
that's a 10-year generation 10 years
seven years from now
you are not going to be interacting with
your consoles in the same manner because
your level of Tolerance will not be the
same you're not going to stand for any
type of loading times the the our Wi-Fi
and our internet structure will be
stronger and more robust therefore not
for needing the facilitation of a device
you will have input straight across they
will be apps both of these guys so I
don't think I get the PlayStation 5 will
probably be the pro will probably be the
last iteration of accomplishment
interesting inside of gaming understands
that the next generation of PlayStation
px6 is unlikely to release until at
least 2028 that will put the current
console current generation console
schedule line with its predecessors
salute to Tom on this one this is
interesting this is interesting
so off the back it do feel I see I see
both sides because off the back it do
feel weird because they feel like we
didn't even really get crooked on this
gym
like so we do feel weird [__] that you
know the the the chips or just how hard
it was to find a console and stuff like
that and um yeah and I salute the time
on this one I do want to give credit to
the to the home team though thank you
you're credited to the home team losing
gaming.net was on this you know what I
said shout out to my man mods Gaming we
did we did have this uh on about um you
know a patent suggested that A PS5 Pro
could be in the making that time we got
dragged we got dragged for this and um
yeah it was pretty much uh the the
patent was called scalable game console
CPU GPU design for Home console and to
King's Point cloud gaming the patent
describes technology that would allow
multiple SOC chips system one chip to be
connected with a high-speed on cocaine
buses forming even bigger chips this
technology could then be used for
creating a light version of the console
which would be like a base PS5 and the
high-end version using multiple chips
with grading process greater processing
and storage capability this could
suggest a PS5 Pro so Lords of gaming.net
was on this as well so um look you know
yes I think it's potentially gonna be
happening you know obviously with um
inside gaming and Tom is saying as far
as the patent by Mark Cerny looking to
accelerate Ray tracing in uh in games
um
is my thing like
I see the pushback
but I ain't gonna lie to y'all
if there's a better version of something
that is literally my hobby and what I
play yeah and I am literally the king
you know this I am we are literally the
guys
that every two years yo the ultra the
ultra 23 4 is out yo you know what I'm
saying so I could sit here and say yo
it's too early right we ain't really
whatever whatever but the data show
there's a market for it you know there's
a market for elite controllers there's a
market 699 though and if we look at
history
remember when this is not this is
history repeat itself in a way because
PlayStation 4 Pro he was like yo who did
that why is that why didn't you I needed
it we all got it we all got it I needed
it as soon as you see the digital
Foundry joint and then oh this is doing
the ray tracing this one you need it
you're saying this one doing 120 and
you're like man and the game industry
it's a lot of fomo let's be real if you
see a significant performance
on one particular platform or one
particular mid-generation refreshing you
see the tangible visible difference yeah
like this is hitting that 60
consistently this got the ray tracing
this got all the bells and whistles of
your beloved game and then you see the
the other version that you currently
have yeah
your vrr ain't kicking it yeah
it is what it is so look I am definitely
the target audience
so you think this one I have a full rdna
too
well you know there was 8K on the box
do you think this this one there finally
put the fastest
my SSD is normal over here we will
discuss the SSD that it is interesting I
mean like um you know I will say this
you know PlayStation get that output
still been a very good position kick you
know in the terms of what
in terms
it puts them in a good position to do
what
um listen they're not getting rid of
places the real problem is the
PlayStation 4. um let's keep it a buck
he's holding us back me no I get that
and we that comes down to game design
right game design is held back with the
bass these bass systems we don't have I
agree no I come down to a decision to
cutting somebody off right yeah at some
point right there's also gonna be a cut
off at some point once there's enough
PS5 window because they said 2025 though
yeah I don't know Superman when James
gun dropped Superman that's that's when
they're gonna drop the PlayStation 4 but
I hear you you know so the question then
becomes you know they drop that I will
say this okay if you're seeing Miles
Morales and you seeing Wolverine on a
PlayStation 5 Pro looking substantially
crazy I ain't saying that there's not a
market for this right right that's all
I'm just talking about the because I I'm
not I'm not even arguing with you I'm
talking about I'm seeing comments like
who needs this why and I get it because
people like yo the generation didn't
even cook it but I am of the mindset
that when you see it and it's a tangible
difference the game is going to have
that fomo and they are going to buy this
not to be fair though yeah the pro never
really sold like the base copy right
true yeah sure really so I think I think
if we look at it how how well did the
series X I mean the series X does Xbox
One sorry I don't know I don't know but
I know it's sold better than that that
wooden box
that we had I know I know uh the the
first time we had actual 4K 60 frames
per second in the forza right you know
that was a tangible uh thing listen it's
gonna sell and it's gonna sell to to the
fools like ourselves yes I've been
talking on it yeah yeah listen yeah I
need my destiny running at uh 16 race
racing on I need these things my thing
is yes you're never ever going to see
what you think you're going to see from
the upper end of these consoles oh okay
because you talk about the older being
right the lowest common denomination
there is always going to be that tether
to the lowest common denominator and
people want to look over and blame the
little s
what about you guys right
what about you guys on the PS4
you know because they have they they
have their own little man he's he's
smaller than the little man we got like
yellow homie is definitely pulling up
the red of my little homie uh he hold my
little homie bags and
that dude is really holding your homie
back right so when do y'all gonna really
wake up I mean fine buy the PlayStation
5 Pro but when you purchasing on the
application at the bottom tell them to
kick that little man to the side so you
can actually see green but that bass is
strong bro like that's a still but you
see they still you know co-developers
yeah we heard it what was it the uh Last
of Us right we were talking about the
factions potentially having a PS4 you
know mode the multiplayer that kind of
bit so they're they're in an interesting
position because there's still a lot of
PS4s out there and stuff but of course I
got to ask is what kind of like solve
alluded to which is like
what does Xbox do because because here's
the day you know I'm saying like you
said you know
um if history repeats itself PS4 Pro was
out and then Xbox One X Scorpio yeah
came about like a year after right so do
we see a situation where Microsoft feels
the need to respond because let's be
honest if the digital Foundry start
coming out in that PS5 yes it's smashing
Xbox you going to sit there tell me
Jason Ronald to the team ain't big
cooking yeah Phil made it clear like
that's not a narrative we're gonna lose
again exactly you know the Dominus do
not like that power talk since his
regime has come King he's always said we
will never be the butt of the joke on
the power ever again that's your [__]
and I think he'll hold true to his work
this is the problem where you run into
and and this is and I'm pretty sure that
Jason right on the team is looking at it
from this aspect fine it's no problem to
do a series X pro okay boom you do it
right so you made your series actually
relevant that you made enough to even
utilized series XXX Ultra yeah
XXL
so check it out though do you okay so do
you do you at that point
does the regular series X become the new
little man a little man that's what I'm
saying because think about this kid you
gotta get yourself get finished oh but
that's the thing though right but I
think we saw that last night too the
same thing where it was like the 1s is
what stage yes right and the in the big
box VCR went away yes y'all went away it
was already an improvement it was
smaller it cost less
I don't know yeah it could be a thing
where the series X is what goes away and
little man stays and maybe what about
this let me give you another scenario I
don't know why don't you just upgrade a
little man so if you upgrade a little
bit the series s Ultra so do you do a
dual screw
a big cocktail generation refresh they
have no choice they have to do it that
way they pigeon hold themselves to a
manner that you have to phase out the
regular series as and the regular series
X phase those two out have that regular
you know the um the X Ultra the series s
Ultra right
um You have to kill off those two skus
you got it crazy so but the series
how mad would the world be I would I got
three of them B I want to be upset to a
level
yo
all right you know what they need they
need memory right yeah this is the
problem
these these weak consoles and they're
weak memory wise they need memory right
because the series s is is held back by
its constraints in the memory and the
ram
let's say you fix those things now he's
on par with your ex right and you gotta
phase out the X because now but but the
Lord
he said in King if you phase out both
see we're gonna see you with impacts
brother he said if you phase out bro
that's a new generation
you're starting a new generation if
you're Xbox if you do that and then if
you do that you run the risk of
dreamcasting yourself yes and being
caught in the middle when the next pH
when the pH six comes but it doesn't
come out I know we're gonna get them for
that but
my question why can't let me ask you
this why can't a scenario exist
where little men
still stays there he's the lowest common
denominator what he gonna do he gonna do
what he gonna he's gonna give you clouds
a ditto console
and you're gonna force people this is
this is the haircut let's go let's get
it let's get it oh Megamind
um you you gonna force people to stream
they all died already no his little man
gave you options of streaming little man
they got their discs
all right so you download little man
won't be able to handle anything
if we go upwards and beyond crazy shout
out to Microsoft for actually leaving
the generation behind they left Xbox one
behind but right now little man is at
the precipice so if you bring out a a
double XL uh Series S
little man is stuck like you took away
the Gap there right so you got these
high-end games and little man's like I
can't do that and then then what little
man has to stream it I mean you are
streaming all the Azure company you are
the person that told the Xbox one
generation if you can't play these
robust games you can stream the bigger
but I do think at that point at that
point if you sort of eliminate if you if
you eliminate the option of little man
realistically being able to play these
games locally at that point you know
what do you drop that price to because
at that point it goes back to that that
piece of Hardware that piece of Hardware
that got sort of uh put on the Shelf
where you know they were talking about
just the streaming box right so it's
like man become Lockhart it really does
have to become little man need to be a
hundred dollars then yeah it needs to be
a hundred dollars at that point so with
the controller all right so let's keep
it let's keep it a buck though let's
keep it a b does little man become
Lockhart I mean well he is lost he is
along the way yeah does he become that
and then here's the question remember
with Scorpio came out they was talking
yeah and one s would still exists but as
addict as a 1s my brother addict had
that what else we remember how rough
some of the reports was when you talk
about playing Gears of War he was like
my level wasn't loaded it's fast
and then eventually do do you think it's
a slow phase out and then series X
becomes the new little man and and what
you call it pro or XL I don't think they
we did they abandoned the series as
people though okay I don't I think we're
too early on if we had a proper
trajectory and we were really into the
third year of of these consoles third or
fourth year into these consoles that we
have right now
um then I would say yeah but we haven't
even seen these consoles reach anywhere
like they haven't we're we are really
playing last generation games now right
you know we haven't really cracked that
uh let's get to the next level let's
crack this mole I think those games are
starting to come this year and oh and I
think with Starfield I think Starfield
ushers us into uh this generation what
it's supposed to be right and I think
the scale from that way uh how Starfield
performs as ambitious as it is I think
it's only able to be done on current
generation hardware and I think we start
to see a game from Sony that uh utilize
current generation uh Hardware assets
and stuff that we need now so
um we we start to live this year
and and we don't have we didn't have any
time with I think little man is at a
huge disadvantage because of kovit even
though covet helped little man be the
way he's at
I think little man is the odd man out I
mean it's interesting song we ask you
this before I was gonna ask you like we
we kind of oh [__] we going out a little
man but we just we we're thinking it for
this big Generation stuff applies to
Xbox I mean but we after a bit too
little man still has already hit A2 he
has all these things it's the GP it's
the like like he said like King said
it's it's less RAM and a less powerful
GPU okay that's it yeah so do you think
everybody here's the flip side
this is a successful console for them
that's the problem right so
again is a scenario where you really can
cut him out because he's I mean they
even made Headway in Japan on some level
right you know in in different regions
and now
do can you realistically cut about can
the idea of little man still existing
and
coexisting with with the bigger model of
an XL
I can see a scenario where the you mean
current little man little man existing
with a mid-generation that's that's
tough because the thing about it is that
the disparities going the disparity is
going to be bigger right if you already
seeing the complaints right and
warranted or not right
the thing about it is the devs that are
complaining about this are either don't
have the bandwidth to put the time and
effort they need to to get those those
versions up to Snuff right or really is
too more more work than they think it's
worth right and if this thinking is
prevalent throughout the industry and
we're not really hearing that then you
know they're going to be excited to see
a little man go right now at the same
time you replace current little man you
need to replace it with a product that's
better at the same price point
minimum better at the same price point
um
I don't know
I don't know if I don't know if you just
don't take the L on the C on dropping
the series X oh
as bringing it down to little man being
the new little man the new little man
the little man
the saw phase out where you're we're
giving you much more power than you had
before for the same price that you were
getting and then and then you have the
series X pro whatever it is so we have a
series X only games
yes yes I I think and you bring the
Baseline up right so then you guys hit
little man you hit little man with Cloud
only then like I said yeah I can hit you
with this okay let's go right and this
is the only way it happens and this is
the only way you say face
you turn little man into and I think
that internally this is the reason why
we never saw that streaming device oh
right okay because you can internally
by default turn little man and it's a
lock on into the streaming device right
and shipping with a controller sell them
for 150 bucks and put
shut up
you say digital only for some games and
you put it on the box and downloadable
for some games right so it has the
flexibility to do both so all the old
games you was able to download before
and play locally off the drive is great
all the other games that you have you
know indie games and stuff like that
that comes in under a couple of one gig
or whatever that's great
um you don't have to do any alterations
to little man all your alterations that
you do do is to make sure that this
series uh double XL is the more powerful
uh console right yeah
right then little man
in that lower price point will continue
to sell how he's supposed to sell and
you don't alienate the initial crowd
that purchases them because you will
have a riot for those people that
purchase little man and now getting the
value out of little man you face a
little man out you just actually
transfer transformed little man into
that streaming boxes capable to do so
you already have the um infrastructure
for that and that's the only way you can
combat Sony doing a PlayStation 5 Pro
because they they remember
they're digital and their PlayStation 4
with the disk drive the only difference
is is the fact that it's no disk drive
so they're not losing when they put out
a PlayStation 5 Pro they just really
just have a PlayStation 5 and a
PlayStation 5 Pro uh the digital thing I
think they're gonna go digital anyway
with the disk drive from them opposed to
that I think maybe the PlayStation 5 Pro
is that that machine that has the
detachable disk drive as well I mean
according to Tom Tom said there's two
there's a that's just something
that driver but he's saying the plate
the the PS5 Pro is still a separate
excuse yeah you know I know about that I
got this basics
it's um but there's also research and
development and sometimes it comes down
to what makes sense where right so does
it make sense for us to introduce uh two
different Hardware iterations at the
same time or within six to seven months
of each other makes absolutely no sense
is a way that we can combine these
things to make it uh more impactful to
the consumer I think Series S continuing
to say exactly what it is but get phased
off to a a
digital uh streaming console only is the
way for Microsoft to be flexible in its
approach later on because if they don't
and they try to give you two different
skus while phasing out another other
excuse just like you said they are
restarting their generation right to
another generation so I think you're
right yeah but I think we have to also
just look at the fact that these two
apart from the VR thing where Sony's
doing their own thing these two kind of
do things hand in hand all the time they
launch around the same time when they
drop new generate they know what each
other is doing
so it does kind of feel like if this is
real from Sony and have no reason to
believe it's not that it will be a
situation where Microsoft will match it
just because again they're the two
they're the two that are in the same
Lane right so yeah and we we've had
we've had Jason on well Jason you know
they were designing little man and
series X you you know these things are
set in motion years and years and
they're already working on the next
stuff you know it feels and that has
also said that kind of stuff but it is
interesting because they had taken the
Dual SKU approach this gen how they
handle it right that's the fun one what
do they do with that so it'll be
interesting but yeah I do think there
will be a response I think
um the question is is it in line I guess
my only question is is it in line timing
wise
in proximity with PS5 Pro or do they
take the Scorpio approach where they let
PS4 Rock PS4 Pro rock out first
see what they did and then came behind
them like was it like a year later or
something like that because it wasn't
the same yeah it was it was the
following it was the following year we
got the Scorpio so yeah it'll be
interesting and it is it is it's a
different time I do think um to King's
Point because everyone's kind of coming
at little man or whatever a little bit
but to King's Point PlayStation is in a
similar situation because there's still
the PS4 out there yeah they act like PS4
yeah the PS4 isn't out there right so
it's like and we still we're talking
about Last of Us factions that still
have not coming out but we know now at
least the rumors suggest that there is a
PS4 factions mode so
yeah
I just find it funny that
they're being held up fractions is never
going to be what y'all expected to be
right it's supposed to be this grandiose
thing this PlayStation 5 thing no it's a
PlayStation 4 thing it's just like God
of War Ragnarok right it's the ultimate
PlayStation 4 game that's playable on
your PlayStation 5. that's exactly
what's gonna happen to factions and I
don't care what anybody says people can
sit there and say oh that's great I'll
deal with that if it has that same
quality I'm all the way live with that
no fool
you are getting a game that could have
been so much more but it's not it's
being held back but just saying it's
held back and it looks great imagine
what it could have looked like if it
wasn't held back so factions will be
held back and it will have a ceiling on
its head and look great but it's the
best PlayStation 4 game it's a good
point you know it's a good point and uh
it's funny it's funny he cared about
mine right now rest in peace after this
code you know these are the kind of
discussions we would have yeah about
game design and game design being held
back and you see you know on both sides
on some level like kick is saying it's
true you know what I'm saying what are
you saying true which is that you know
there's always that lowest common
denominator and again these things get
like PC we get it you know what I mean
but at the same time you know what could
have been and maybe this is just a new
era we're in right now because of the
way the skus are and things oh I want to
shout out on Tom Henderson he said by
the time Pia he's actually the chat
salute the legend he said by the time
PS5 Pro releases you he said if it is
holiday 2024 he says PS5 sales will be
on par with how the PS4 sales were when
the PS4 Pro releases and then we yeah
we'd even talk about that with the sales
and then chip availability so it does
make sense it does line up the sources
do line up man with with ours Tom I got
to give us the home team Lord's game
without next credit
699 yes yes that's the price yeah 6.99
oh come on I'll put it right now I'll
tell you right now
it's five it's gonna be five don't
listen to this dude don't listen to this
dude don't listen to him it's I told you
how much that VR was gonna be it said it
was exactly like I said uh this is gonna
be six nine nine you know six they're
not slashing no price on the regular
place so okay when you saying the PS5
Pro gonna be six seven hundred nine get
it on the lay down if you enter you what
is he doing for that it's gonna do what
you say
120 frames we might have Ray tracing hey
that AK on the box really means AK on
the box
coming out yo you five six nine you want
it or not
why are you looking in my window if your
pockets ain't calling that's PS3 I'm
none yo okay question uh how much is
PlayStation VR with that game all right
the VR by itself
with the game it's six
and an extra hundred dollars
and you got a pro I'm acting like the
price and he did what was the pro let's
do this the pro the pro was bored four
four
yeah the PlayStation was 300.
it'll be five it'll be five it's yo okay
hey man the pro was four right okay and
the Scorpio was five wasn't it yeah
how's your knees doing these days I'm
really animate on this one on this one
6.99
listen
649 dollars is your uh the PlayStation
VR too it's not six foreign
[Music]
es5 Pro and they go say and they go show
you all the features yeah they're gonna
drop that price off
and you know what if you don't want to
buy it right now available
if you don't like it we got a console
for UA station it's not necessary you
don't need these Pro features like if
you don't have a lot of these it says
700 699 with Wolverines
as much as I think you ridiculous with
this price yes if they drop Wolverine in
the Box Pro dudes is gonna pay that
700.
same move for readers out now
what is the PlayStation 5 Pro price
five to five fifty
I'm sorry
and it'll be a six with a game if they
six with a game so all right let me
schedule a little bit I'm here let's say
let me scare you by that time we will
read Wolverine will be ready right
somebody else
again what if they got a custom PS5 Pro
yellow with the claws and the packet
limited edition Wolverine let's write
down that exact terminology yes
let's go ahead and add a man to your
scratches
listen
what I care about is that price tag says
yo when they say it because you know how
I know they so high on life with they
self right now I love this I love that
they feeling theyself right now if they
even got this talk out there and you
guys are mixing it up yes 6.99 it's not
gonna hurt you why because that call a
little while in that box
and then
they always have this 100 200 price gap
for the lowest common denominator the
PlayStation 5 will be the regular one
will be that little man for y'all to get
in I would joy song because I think it's
a slave duck I am worried about show
these hubris with this yes
I am doing soft talks anyway I'm big
scared it's a part of me that is like
they could pull it off not that I agree
I think it's a ridiculous station three
remember how much I paid for it and they
haven't made that mistake since
they do they lost the generator they
low-key lost the generation doing that
doing that like
I'm talking about official Sony 699 tag
right and I don't care what they put in
the Box they can put little children for
you here
I don't care but what I say is if they
drop anything they say 6.99 your niece
is mine and I don't care how they get to
that number but see that but that gives
you so much leeway though hey bro that's
your problem
yeah it's not that much leeway because
all right shout out to Tom Henderson
he's saying 699 could make sense in a
bundle with the Dual second duel says
Wolverine yellow console admit
okay how you rationalize it if addict
evaluate he'd be salad would take this
attic would take this no yeah he oh I
wish he was here for this one we gotta
see bro what y'all think I mean the
torch I'm taking that one put some
prices in the chat yo I'll take the
attic bro what y'all take a PS5
well like the PlayStation VR gonna be
300.
I said nah I said that drink will be
5.99 yeah this is like man it will never
do that surprises
[Laughter]
surprise I was so right and I'm gonna
tell you right now y'all y'all keep on
hold on
what's up wet Choice 600 Timber 650
Stitch 650 Loki 600. see what we use 600
Z black oh Z Black Friday 800. Jesus
Jesus oh he really called it Nick 599.94
why 94 cents though
Charlie 600 Don sicario 6669 PS5 fuzzy
said 600. Supremacy 600 now I'm 600.
pixel bit Connor with King 650 to seven
Tara is 600. they served 700 600 Corey
Tidewell 800 Stitch as the pawn Prius
five is 550 okay Tom 800 650 it's all
over the place though it's not really
consistent more 600s than everything
song on epon seven K Asanti what you got
600 to 650 with no games okay PS4 hoggy
should dps5 will be 650 uh since the
average price of the PS5 is 550 gig is
likely right 700 bad man 700 pounds but
you're talking British we gotta see how
that um transfer rate is uh 650 wow this
is all low but uh some people don't say
it's everybody dude this is all over the
place wow this is gonna be interesting
all right
yo because I remember okay W one
thousand dollars I remember when y'all
was yelling out that PlayStation VR and
I told y'all start the cat they were
coming before you do let me hear the
legendary we got slow-mo 600 we got um
our break protocol Super Chat General
Mac cause you just put it in right now
649 but not Tom Henderson
500 as digital
600 where they drive
I'm going with Tom I think Tom put down
your addiction
okay I have a feeling Tom knows
prediction
Tom you know and I know
the retail Department ain't going with
what's on that white sheet right so we
know who wins all the time
when they're going right then and saying
well what's the pricing structure
Financial dudes don't care about none of
the stuff that you're talking about
market trends said you guys will
initially Pony up
6.99 so how about you said someone was
your drink
mine was five to five fifty six with
some would it be the price
not get a base price so I can put this
pole for you come on let's get a base
price the base price space what number
612 say it since they were willing to go
550 with the with the headset 550. oh
okay so you said 550 okay so basically
you have the PS5 Pro okay all right so
we putting it up right now you're gonna
see all right hit the votes hope I did
this right hit the floor yeah it's up
hit the votes we gonna see by the end of
the chat where this is at this is a fun
one I don't know Chad is all over the
place oh now don't back away downtown
disclaimer no inside info no no
make sure we get our credit that um he
said the 500 PS5 is digital 600 with a
job thank you Tom Henderson for your
fantastic investigative reporting you
are a gentleman and a scholar for
breaking this world renowned news on
iron
it's gonna be a fun one y'all it's gonna
be a fool he's laughing you know it's
fun for a lot of people
yo I've seen it I've seen you what is
the last time
what was PS3 690 it wasn't it was five
minutes no it wasn't it was 6.99 for the
Whatchamacallit for that whole um um
remember the big robust pack or if you
remember that but the foreign
I was walking I
with that console in one game if they
paid for that and they haven't made that
business
your mother stuff we got this regime
right now that need to stab on them that
they need to hurt themselves
this is they they're in it right now one
they lost they launched the peripheral
that one nobody was really asking for
except for like probably five or six uh
Playstation One VR all right so they got
it out there right now right and they
say maybe and remember the last
PlayStation 4 Pro came out because the
PlayStation 4 needed more power to run
the VR
now this could be the same scenario in
history repeating itself right
PlayStation 5 Pro is more vrr friendly
six hundred dollars right is the console
price now they need to show it's a
little bit more Superior this is a
premium product I will say if they sh if
they could showcase 30 get out there I
think they can when they start talking
about them is it they start I think he
starts showcasing power regardless of
whatever the price is
gave us according to people I think they
will showcase a difference yeah yeah I
forget in history is repeating itself
and we had all these same conversations
last time and a month before when they
announced everybody was like of course
it was five of course I'm looking at the
poll 152 votes kids everybody
wants to fly close to the sunlight
Icarus an Icarus fell and died
remembering is we had the same
conversation with the PlayStation VR2
and you guys said they will be
absolutely crazy and this will be
suicidal if they launch that console
higher than 350. I understand
seven dudes it was going to be 600 y'all
looked at me and said yo you are nuts I
told you it was going to be 1200 to 1300
combined with a PlayStation 5. and y'all
say king you are bugging no
no king is right and I'm telling you now
699 is gonna be your bang when y'all see
it when they say it don't be surprised
because I'm not this is gonna be the
best knees that I love because I told
y'all gonna act like y'all don't know
this dude's a snake like no he's a cute
little teddy bear he is not a cute
little teddy bear this is a snake and
he's gonna bite you when the price come
out and y'all see the price and they're
gonna they're gonna tell you I'm like
let's go
8K 123s
super super super fast SSD with more RAM
with super super
yes everything everything is rape Ray
tracing Butters this is fantastic and
then they're gonna walk off the stage
and Jim dance moves Ryan gonna say 6.99
and all you're gonna hear the crowd go
oh no
and you can hear me in the background
I'm doing this with the other team
yeah
so you can say whatever you want to say
I know they like money and this they got
you because y'all really want this Y'all
Gonna Get It 6.99 Sony go get them
what's the Evermore crew of charge
people
pay more oh man this is funny shout out
to the chat uh yeah 173 votes currently
in 80 percent agree with King
700.
look at the choir
yeah it is worth it
I can't wait that is 100 true they are
the only dudes
on the box but these dudes could put 700
on the box and I'm gonna tell you this
the day they gonna do it they're gonna
put it out and they're gonna say 700.
Microsoft is going to come right behind
them like hour two later oh series X
double XL uh yeah that'd be 550.
payback you gotta see it it's more
powerful see you later look that
generation Refreshers could be here we
will be staying tuned this is good so is
it official yeah you're not even messing
with this for you I know I'm taking it
yeah
it's been a while it's been a while we
did a fun one so again you know this is
two years out right now we got it
because you know kid you better be on
your Square because Saul will record you
listen he's been known
I'm fine what's gonna be unfined because
when they do it they had a state of play
and when when after Mark Sunny do his
spill and Jim walks off the stage and
the number's gonna come up here myself
I'm gonna send myself a text right now
to remind me what episode what episode
is this kind of IOP I believe
put yourself in the future too and put
yourself in the future because you know
how you like to go back in there yeah
put the wet wipes
296 yes yes it's the Harold Goldberg
slash Tom Henderson episode
where King slotted my legs
told me and my kneecaps were four 6.99
PS5 bro I hope Sony used a wooden blade
on your knees
so solve for the record the bending knee
is 550 for a PlayStation 5 Pro and for
the record King 700. right
for the knock knock all right let me go
see it is better Dodge I heard it here
[Music]
let's get to see what chance and then we
finish up with the last time
we always get a couple right at the end
I was like let me get the ones that I
copy pasted already
um let me see
[Music]
um
you know we do how they love stuff like
this
oh we got Andy Cruz two dollar Super
Chat best podcast In The Biz keep doing
your thing absolute
then we got Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat green station asking for our
kidneys fan that's right it's gonna come
with free nft
shout out to hargit to Diva before when
your 20 Super Chat forget the PS5 pro
pro play on PC's theme and you got a
bunch of codes you gave a original post
hello Spider-Man code of Miles Morales
coder got a war cold day it's gone and
Uncharted the Lost Legacy
thank you brother appreciate that Master
base in the building
yeah yeah we got Muhammad Ishmael 10 or
10 pound Super Chat keep up the good
work guys always cracks me up on a
Sunday from a new subscriber from London
thank you oh blessings thank you
appreciate you man then we got Corey
Tidwell five dollars which had the
upgraded consoles will aim for full raid
tracing at higher frame rates that alone
makes a huge difference it's for
enthusiasts we said the same thing about
the PS4 Pro we said the same thing about
the about the Scorpio
yup you're gonna be enthused with that
practice let me ask you was the PS5 and
the series X not for enthusiasts yeah we
was enthusiastic about it too bro
I'm crazy about this somebody just super
I mean someone just uh Twitter us the
PlayStation 3 press conference with the
actual pricing with the 16 and they had
it with they had it by skews so the 20
big one was 500 they said a 60 gig one
was 69 6600 yeah 99 that's mine don't
get a second job uh Mr Benjamin 20 Super
Chat I see series that's as an entry
series X will be for casual and series
Ultra is for the hardcore they all take
a hundred dollar hit so you don't
eliminate any of the other skews you
just add a skew I don't know we gotta
see and we got Raiden blade member for
two years two pounds for chat Series S
consoles not in Cloud that not in Cloud
that yes or no
say it again that's what it says
consoles and not in Cloud comma not in
Cloud that comma yes or no
I believe that um Series S at some point
in time will be the the cloud
um console yeah you can try to download
stuff on it but you know
it'll depend you know things it's going
to be depending on how that's going to
run once those servers actually get to
the point where it's just not series X's
that's inside the service completely and
we don't know you know what's the
percentage of that yet but once that
happens and then the ultra comes out
they're gonna be uh removing those
blades and putting Ultra blades in there
that where does that leave the series us
you know yeah yeah
I can see Xbox doing what Nintendo did
with the 64 One release it upgrade pack
for the current Series S to catch it up
an upgrade pack to cast it up to the new
model or they release a series r
that was something that was physical and
then split the demographic even though
the rampack was necessary for other
games it looked fantastic it actually
really probably doomed the console it
did because not everybody had it yeah
exactly we got JD gamer remember for two
years twenty dollars Good Day to all the
Lords I believe the little man will
probably Remain the base because the new
Nintendo switch will essentially be at
the same power levels guaranteeing the
game's a program for for that level yeah
from what we heard and them having
problems with the bad compatibility of
it I don't know what the power levels is
going to be going to be no series uh
they made they may decide not to go
Tigra I mean I don't know because they
have they have a long deal with with
Nvidia right it's like 10 years or
something like that so
we got my name is mud five dollars
it's my Pro will be 500 dollars with the
disk drive optional yeah okay
yo you guys y'all act like you've never
been beat up by some y'all guys really
have Goldfish Memory like that dude
ain't never punching your face and he
just punched you in your face just two
weeks ago with that PlayStation VR you
thought you was gonna get the 300 for
y'all
Square in your mouth and I told you it
was gonna happen you fitting to do it
again he winding up the fist right now
in front of your face and you just
sitting there like nah he ain't gonna
punch me he's Gonna Knock You Out
PS5 Pro 500 PS5 slim 400 this drive will
be optional for both
guys
yo I'm gonna tell you when bullies beat
you up they don't care son they don't
care about your feelings your feelings
was in the numbers
you was opening those numbers yeah I
hope you learn how to duck a weave
yes yeah we got Corey Tidwell 2010.
savvis High
too close to the Sun
gotta be rational about these things it
can't be irrational you better go get a
shell of a PlayStation
messy and we got Joe back you know how
they sell the the box for 500 and you
don't read the fine print and you get a
PlayStation five boxes from eBay
then we got a general back rubber for
two years two dollar Super Chat 649.99
that's just prediction 649.99 yeah
that's that's that's pretty cool you
know with taxes 700. ridiculous welcome
to my room
and we got Corey Tidwell 200 200 two
dollars 800 because of the super duper
ssds
and then we got the pixel bit G member
for two years two dollar Super Chat when
is the price drop for the currently hot
PS5 yeah
it ain't coming down
Icarus died just like little Timmy did
dope yeah we got hearty five dollars to
the chat profit SOB you might be right
but would you have predicted console
price increases we're in a crazy world
right now it could be seven hundred
dollars I'm gonna tell you right now the
financial crisis telling you
seven please
then we have Lucius Augustus five
dollars of a chat SOB there's zero
chance Sony sells you a PS5 Pro in 2024
for the same price as a PS5 in 2023
which is 550. 150 more dollars for a pro
model is like when have you ever seen
this never you guys have never seen this
happen before yeah I never seen them
also releasing console and come back a
couple of days y'all are basing this on
like y'all have anecdotal knowledge that
this has happened before welcome to this
level no we're basing it off of who
doing it
do I need to sell my soul to afford the
8.99
he come with a soul-based contract
Miss Fisto comes in the Box
Let Me Go My Name Is Mud two dollars for
chat series XL could be 800 Microsoft
has Game Pass they're not gonna do that
they're not doing that they better not
come out I know who can't say that prank
that's right I know I know who's really
deal with it
then we got Andy Cruz two dollar Super
Chat 650 700 Jim is loving this oh Jim
is in the chat right now he watching
like yeah that's the price that guy
knows
that guy with the shades knows
that we got let's put the crust in the
chat for Lord gold Raven 645 thank you
sir appreciate you appreciate you then
we got uh My Name Is Mud again two
dollar Super Chat everyone thought the
1X was going to be 600 dollars and it
wasn't it was wasn't it wasn't it
was five it was 550 right now
I'm totally looking at the taxes that
tax is not retail price no no but I'm
probably looking at the taxes and what I
purchased I think I purchased it came up
to like six hundred dollars so then we
have Hotel I gotta go back for one more
Raven two six uh 45 two dollars for chat
y'all are so entertaining to keep up the
good job and this was that was his first
Super Chat
much love welcome to the realm
Lord bronze uh just showing some love
can't wait to see your Pax coverage
R.I.P Timmy hashtag Gone Too Soon
I'm not going soon enough I mean
sorry this is a king just increasing the
price of everything the warrant his
seven Hollow dollar price day I agree no
no I'm actually not I believe that the
Baseline is gonna be 6.99
you're gonna get this work you're gonna
get this work you'll see and when you
guys see y'all just look over at me and
be like I'm just gonna have a smile
Robert Kelly
no we got the song Lucius
Lucius maybe I don't think we got Lucius
no I got lucious yeah let us know who we
missing though we will take care of it
continue yeah
yeah let us know was it akw who wrote I
don't know he just said so if you missed
one but he didn't say which one so so
akw let us know which one the name of
the person we'll continue
okay and we had he said My Name Is Mud I
could have swore he got all my name is
Sirius XL can be 800 Microsoft has Game
Pass I read that one
uh
[Music]
Icarus The Icarus died just like little
Timmy there is one that says two dollars
everyone thought the 1X was going to be
600. yeah we said that okay all right I
said that yeah anything else all right
hopefully we get it back
then we have Andy Cruz two dollars Super
Chat 650 700 Jim is lovely I read that
already actually I think it's well back
down
uh JD gamer was always objective view
yes
SOB I'm sorry about your knees the
current PS5 is 50 is 550 worldwide
literally everywhere but the USA no way
they make their Pro unit less I expect
600. you said it correctly sir in the
USA we are different we are separate
from the rest of the world
if it's 699 pounds that is not 699 thank
you very much
that we got Corey Tidwell by those which
said I ain't never fight nobody I made
them look like nobody who said this yo
uh then we got my joystick is tired
just take me now King I'll not charge
700 oh my god oh whoa whoa can you take
them knees
what to be taken next next next uh
yeah
yeah take them down
[Music]
hashtag peace love life send mad love to
level one gaming they reaches over 2000s
shout out to fame shout out to Baron
shout out to everybody over there do you
doubts
loyalum salute
for my man 108 dragons
oh my God you made the mistake of
telling us about your birthday way too
damn early than the actual day came and
everybody forgot
happy belated birthday I'm glad you're
on demand we will see you in June yeah
because normally we get him at Pax with
us but you know yeah
absolute the 108 man
okay yeah we're good right now all right
no doubt final time put the 700 to the
side
so uh yeah this is King's topic oh
surprisingly
let's finish the day oh wait wait before
we start the topic we have 500 and uh
some odd change uh let's get those likes
up yeah
I need before you start the topic I need
the SSD and the Sony baby uh voice
dude
yeah shout out to King to bring this to
my attention uh Ratchet and Clank Rift
apart could be potentially the rumors it
could be potentially the next uh
Playstation PC Port uh King's favorite
uh developers so these uh Nexus software
could be that's my heart
could be planning to make Rift apart the
next PlayStation on PC port a new job
description for the developer or known
for uh porting over Spider-Man and Miles
Morales hence that is looking for an
engineer with experience in technology
that is essential to insomniac's our
latest Ratchet and Clank gang and this
is a UI engineer
um talking about coherent this is in
reference to using coherent middleware
so this coherent Labs middleware is
featured on one of the games that's
featured that uses that is Ratchet and
Clank along with control Ultimate
Edition pubg Minecraft and many more
putting these two pieces of information
together it is reasonable to believe
that Rift apart is nexus's nexus's next
PlayStation PC Port shout out to
PlayStation lifestyle for the article
That a Kick brought to my attention so
uh
what do we have to say about this yeah
y'all holding on the PlayStation all
alone the PlayStation 5 is special
it can only you know the SSD
as an SSD is as fast as me here we go
and ratchika and Clank is a pure
indicative uh showing of how a different
and bespoke the PlayStation is
you know the stuff cannot be imitated
and Ratchet and Clank is the game that
shows you the way it shows you the way
to the PC
and it's gonna happen to you guys you
guys fall for every banana in the teal
pipe y'all listen to everything they say
the electrical in in the air
you know and the SSD is so fast that
sometimes when you're Computing it's
already there I already knew what you
was gonna do
yo what are y'all gonna do with Ratchet
and Clank runs wild
are you implying that a certain
Community was saying that the SSD was
this was an exclusive feature that no
other console can do this the PC can't
handle this
no one this is what makes PlayStation
PlayStation you understand like they
give you things that you can't get no
play y'all all your games is on a piece
you are not special at all and this is
the last game and it's coming over to
the PC what is your excuse now
[Laughter]
oh man where did we start with this yeah
I can hear Mr Han look at you look at
you now over here this is definitely a
look at you now
yes uh solver in King's defense huh
there was a lot of this talk during the
launch of the uh oh no this this is
where I'm with him on the show because
you know if this is true it is it is
quietly being worked on right
um which is a little bit weird just
because considering you know Ratchet and
Clank is I don't know it's kind of
considered more of a kitty game not in
the vein of like a Sackboy game or
whatever but considering how Sackboy
didn't do super well maybe Ratchet and
Clank would be the next thing you put
out but whatever
um but yeah you
know when people are trying to sell you
a new product the console or something
hyperbolic statements give me
part of you know getting YouTube to put
your money down and you know you know
I'm still waiting for 8K on my PSA set
it right on the box so uh yeah
apparently you know PC hard drives have
caught up
a lot of technological leaps
Leaps and Bounds in the uh you know
whatever three years since this game was
lost on PlayStation now yeah so um
looking forward to seeing it on on the
PC it is you know again this is
this is why we gotta laugh at this stuff
because again as consumers yes we know
we're constantly being kind of lied to
right
those words buzzwords marketing speak
lies sometimes but it's just the nature
of it right to get you to put the money
down and invest in you know little to me
Ratchet and Clank is a beautiful game on
on on the PS5 it really is
um but that you know the whole jumping
from Universe to Universe thing is is
kind of a little bit smoke and mirrors
about this I don't remember what this is
this can't be done
he said this this can't be none any
place else but here this morning there
was a Dev one Dev that was trying to say
that it wasn't as special or something
that was definitely that conversation
yeah remember specifically what it was
but they essentially saying that it's
not it isn't rendering both things at
the same time it's something that kind
of sits in cash and in it yeah it's
right so it wasn't this this whole thing
like wow it's rendering this whole
entire world that you only jump to for a
couple of minutes and back at the same
time it's not that right and again those
again in marketing speak those are
details that you know
the more the marketing speak is not
going to tell you right you just gotta
you know tell you the truth so AES is
interesting again it's one of those
things where it's it's super quiet you
know nobody's not making Fanfare about
it Ratchet and Clank because they know
they know the smoke that's gonna come
from this right whether it's you know
it's not narrative it's gonna make or
break anything but it's just funny
because you know
it's funny how
unless King is at the Forefront of yes
of this fight it's funny how we uh
remember Eternal well that can only be
done on the PlayStation
you know the way you die you just gotta
you quickly come back into the world it
allows you only to be done over here oh
I just played return on PC it that was
nice with the PS5 controller that's
right I got all got all my Rumble the
raindrops shout out to KSI said the devs
did come out and say it could be done on
PS4 oh that was it whoa yes right yes
that's true
to say
yeah
so yeah that's it that's it I have too
much to add to it I mean it's what we
say you know say at the time you know
everyone's excited about the new console
right you get the new hallway you know I
remember the unreal is your five demo
all the new man this could only be done
I remember that talk I remember the SSD
talk look we get it you know a lot of
this walking to speak people are excited
about new hardware new console you know
the buzzwords until we get the practical
application I don't really get too
caught up what I need to see but I it
kicks the fast I do remember if support
this is oh no this is hilarious people
this is like hard on this SSD thing for
Rift apart and saying how this was like
to solve the favorite word bespoke and
no other thing can do this and I
remember it was so bad that was the
first time I really seen the PlayStation
Community I mean the PC could be bad at
the place like it was beef in them
streets normally it's XBox guys and so
they got but it would PC guys was like
bruh stop it like I remember that like
it was it was you're gonna tell me this
30 90 TI I can't run this [__] because
at that time because you know why it was
so a funny time in history I got to give
King this is that this is right around
the time pre we believe a generation
this is right around the time we before
we knew about PlayStation and Nexus
relationship right so this was a lot of
people in the PlayStation base still
feeling that exclusives are gonna stay
there there would be no PC ports this is
such a unique thing that the in the
technical engineering of the concert was
so Advanced remember they were like yo
they fought so far ahead that this SSD
and I remember people utilizing the SSD
for all types of technical problems
yeah I I Gotta Give kick this one the
smoke is rightfully giving my kid
because I I remember that like people
were were going extra hard for this
future as if it was solving World Peace
it was it was doing a lot you know what
I'm saying so yeah yeah this is the this
is a fun way to look back on so yeah if
the rumors are true and uh King's
favorite nyxis is that the helm it's a
wonderful job that is king's heart yes
that is favorite remember when he
announced that they announced that
acquisition she came with it
acquisition ever you know what I got I
never told you this but I actually
reached out to Nexus to see if they have
merch I was gonna get you it for your
birthday oh I was trying to get you a
Dixon shirt I could not find like y'all
don't got we're gonna come up with our
own logo yeah we're gonna make it up for
them and um we're gonna get it out to
y'all
I literally I've been trying for like a
year I was like I won an official
not giving you that but normally only
Studios have Birch nah Sony is like no
merch for that dude
shout out to slovo he's everybody who
ran the dump there is a quiet as a mouse
but the north remembers the VC Community
you know slobo I Gotta Give Master ratio
yeah y'all was in the trenches with a
lot of certain fan base certain fan boys
were going at the PC Community extra
hard and it was funny so now it's kind
of funny to see Folsom anyway y'all got
their games you got their base
smoke was given smoke giving smoke
exactly yeah
yeah let's get the um I'm gonna get the
pole or are we gonna get the pole first
then you get the super champs yeah just
in case anything else comes in all right
no doubt no doubt all
slow is so messy in the chat right now
with this PC
um with the rumors of a PlayStation 5
Pro in development how do you think Xbox
should respond to a potential Sony mid
generation refresh choices are a stand
Pat with the series X and S consoles
Xbox should continue its focus on
delivering great games first
B Xbox should already have a mid
generation refresh console ready to
launch adjacent or after the PS5 Pro or
see I don't care because what the hell
you gonna call it the Xbox Super Deluxe
series as Ultra Pro what are you calling
this guy so Rock the vote when it goes
out on Twitter salute to the legendary
Harold Goldberg man he put it down man
he put it going strong at 150 years ago
you're about to hit 200 man that man
breaking the laws of of age and physics
and everything else in science but now
he was a pleasure to listen to oh man so
many great stories I highly advise if
you care about gaming to listen you know
I'm saying illuminary in in the sport
and uh yeah salute to him we probably
have him come come back as well in New
York games critic Circle and our new
game awards but uh so I'm going to get
the super chances then we do our outros
for y'all yes sir no doubt let me get
these super tests real quick no doubt
and I keep making a mistake
[Music]
all right we have
Dragonheart yo remember for one year if
I lost my chat welcome welcome back one
away dragons TV he back to take all
knees he gonna rip your eyes out put him
on you put them on your knees and call
you knees
we got a dark side I've been a peace
love life
got a duality sir
we gotta drive by Joe five dollars I
like that he's a hitter he's a hit he
put it out there in His Name
by Joe then we got 700 could be it I
paid 700 for my PS5 scalper price yes
PlayStation say wait they out here
paying 700 plus yep yeah you wanna know
how much I pay for my PS4 that's that's
what gym it wasn't something yeah Jim so
the price is y'all willing to go for for
the regular
let's get it then we have con artistic
five dollars to pretend I really thought
the podcast was done how long is it
supposed to be again it's just yeah
we have a goal of meat we gotta we can't
leave until we gotta stay until we meet
the girl no this is a marathon okay then
we got God Emperor Sofa King remember
for one month shout out to you Lord
bronze only possible on the holy PS5 SSD
that talk was strong it was a lot of
strong assets as soft I mean slovo says
the north remembers they know
member for 18 months Lord bronze shout
out to the Lord salute to Champ Leon
Edwards removing all doubt he beat
Camaro again again yeah oh wow okay yeah
and tomorrow gave it up okay wow okay
y'all keep killing it gonna miss
watching the fight with you Kane
where can I find people find you what
you got going on Sir nothing getting
ready for packs man it's gonna be a
crazy week the first two Monday Tuesday
working and then just rolling right into
packs it's going to be and then coming
back on Sunday rolling right back into
work so exhaustion is the name of the
game but this is what we do this is a
yearly thing baby so let's get it let's
get it yes sir it'll be fun Lord King
where can I find people find you what
you got going on Sir well right now I'm
going upstairs to eat this dinner yes
but I I I had a a glimpse into somebody
that I find to be truly eclectic yes uh
that word eclectic uh is is exactly how
you describe Harold
um it I anticipated this show for a
while and and you know I don't really
get too excited about certain people but
this guy is somebody that has uh he he's
he's like a Rolodex right and it's just
so many different uh like contacts and
stuff like that that's inside of him or
so many people that he met he sat down
told and told you he sat with Miles
Davis sat down and talked with this guy
for hours
um and he sat with Neil druckman because
they both were sitting there tired and
and had conversations with Neil
um this man is a wealth of knowledge and
also still keeps that youthful
exuberance you know being a hundred and
something years old
our medium that we love but how old is
the general a generalist wonderful Dude
in his heart and to give back and he's
starting in our hometown the Bronx and
he's you know to to Brooklyn next
Brooklyn stand up yeah get out there you
know make sure your support and then we
have Queens of Staten Island and yeah
anyway that we're able to help and help
that stuff grow and grow with them I
cannot wait I mean hopefully we can have
a panel with uh with the kids and talk
about how podcasting goes
relationships with with you with your
friends and getting out doing things and
being positive in that nature I want to
contribute in some form yes absolutely I
want to be a part of that so uh guys
thank everyone I want to thank everyone
who showed up today yes we had close to
600 and some change uh hair all the
people that donated towards you know
going to packs you know super chatted
and and that purchase merch and purchase
pillows all of that stuff is rolled into
it thank you so much I appreciate it for
everybody that is going to Pax uh again
uh Thursday through Saturday we are
going to be there yeah but Laurie is
going to be there to see these pillows
uh and right there in front of your face
you can see the texture inequality there
and the Lords will be there also having
a conversation with you guys so if you
want to see us at valari yes and go see
the pillows and have the conversation
with us pull up we expect you to show up
don't be standoffish welcome to us
because we are family uh Shake our hands
get to know us talk uh we play video
games go to lordsgaming.net get all our
information
get it we're dropping it fast exactly
putting it right there just to be clear
anybody that gets near me is gonna have
to be Frisk first thank you very much
are you gold six to six without
pulled up it got the PS5 pro segment is
our funniest segment in the long time so
definitely yeah that was probably the
reason Harold was amazing so yeah it was
crazy no doubt we had a good day yeah um
yeah so remember if anybody want to
donate a Sunday games
I made a boy in that one right there
but uh yeah man I can't wait Pax is
ready to get ready uh pack up the
suitcase and get out of here on
Wednesday you know straight from work
straight to work and then come back and
go straight to work so remember there's
no IOP next Sunday yeah but we're gonna
have stuff for you during the week yeah
yeah we're gonna have some stuff we got
some stuff cooking up
um yeah I get a salute to the legend
Harold Goldberg you already know again
we got some stuff cooking stay tuned to
the Lord's engagement.net this week
trust me when I tell you stay tuned stay
tuned IOP stay tuned this week
particular fun stuff going Pax will be
called uh cooking again if you guys see
us out there be respectful pull up say
what's up make yourself known in a
respectful way we'll be there we're
gonna get the coverage Fair we got a lot
of stuff cooking there
um again like kitten said valari will be
in the building I already saw him
Laurie's cutting them up they look
fantastic they will be at Pax the laws
will be our packs come check us out
there also by demio lovers I will be in
the bull Thursday
um 1 P.M to 3 P.M please pull up you
want to play DB want to learn about it I
will be at the resolution games Booth I
will get the details for the booth
number as soon as I get that from the
team so come check us out there and then
yeah again this is what we do so PAX
East is huge for us we're gonna have a
lot of coverage stay tuned like King
said we're gonna drop it when we drop
the large larger game ain't gonna be in
there and that's pretty much what I got
anything else before we done wrapping up
out of here good and we'll make sure I
go get that honey man you seek soft out
there reading smooth yo you stupid with
that
King you gotta take come on man what are
you doing gotta join me I can't with
this yes
I can't with this anyway
everybody enjoy your week unless you
guys yeah we got one more Super Chat we
got a faculty radical five dollar Super
Chat thanks for the critical nuance and
insightful gaming dialogue you guys are
the best I always learned so much
PlayStation Diablo 4 so flipping good
thank you brother appreciate it it's a
load no doubt look that's all I got we
are out of here again no IOP next Sunday
we might we're gonna give y'all
something maybe in this place we'll
figure it out we'll see how that goes
but yeah no live IOP most likely on
Sunday but we might give y'all something
and still stay tuned during the week
it's gonna be lit catch y'all later
everybody enjoy your Sunday
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]